vous le mentionnez dans votre rapport
l'année 2022 a été une année hors normes
d'abord avec le phénomène inattendu de
la corrosion sous contrainte qui a fait
l'objet d'une audition spécifique de
l'Office le 27 octobre dernier ensuite
l'été 2022 qui a été marqué par une
canicule et une sécheresse
exceptionnelle qui n'ont pas eu d'impact
sur la sûreté nucléaire mais dont
certaines dérogations aux prescriptions
de rejet thermique ont été
indispensables sur le contexte également
de la guerre en Ukraine la mise en
service de l'EPR qui reste conditionné
dernières étapes à franchir les projets
de petits réacteurs innovants SMR qui
soulève de nouvelles questions de sûreté
ou encore une étape importante du projet
sigo qui ouvre une période d'instruction
durant laquelle la concertation va se
poursuivre
nous avons bien évidemment tous en tête
mes chers collègues ce matin également
les questions liées à l'organisation du
contrôle de la sûreté et de la
radioprotection qui ont mobilisé ces
questions l'office en février dernier
lors d'une nouvelle audition en marge du
projet de loi l'accélération nucléaire
et qui mobilise encore aujourd'hui nos
collègues Jean-Luc Fuji et Stéphane
piénoir qui sont présents et qui ont été
désignés rapporteurs sur cette question
à la suite d'une saisine de la
commission des affaires économiques du
Sénat aussi mes chers collègues j'attire
votre attention sur le fait qu'il n'y a
pas lieu de revenir aujourd'hui sur
l'organisation du contrôle de la sûreté
étant donné le travail en cours de nos
collègues et par respect pour
l'implication qu'il porte à ce travail
nous avons déjà beaucoup à dire ce matin
sur l'état des lieux
à la fois de la Sûreté Nucléaire la
radiopotation pour ce rapport annuel
2022 et nous aurons l'occasion très
prochainement de poursuivre nos débats à
ce sujet sans plus tarder je donne la
parole à Monsieur Bernardo rosuk pour
présenter le rapport de l'ASN sur l'état
de la sûreté nucléaire en France
bonjour à tous
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires merci de
nous accueillir aujourd'hui pour vous
présenter le rapport de l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire au titre de l'année
2022 et début 2023 c'est toujours à un
moment important et un honneur pour la
SN de présenter son rapport annuel tel
que le prévoir vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président la loi je suis
accompagné vous l'avez indiqué mais
comme à l'habitude de membres du collège
du COMEX et de représentants des
services de l'ASM
j'interviendrai dans un premier temps
avec Olivier Gupta puis nous répondrons
collectivement à vos questions
mon propos liminaire comportera une
appréciation générale et trois points
d'attention
j'évoquerai ensuite les principaux
constats par exploitants et par grand
domaine d'activité qui ressort de
l'année 2022 Olivier gusta vous parlera
des échanges et des positions qui ont
été prises au sein de l'association
WENRA association qui réunit les
responsables d'autorité de sûreté en
Europe association qu'il préside
actuellement
tout d'abord concernant l'appréciation
générale de la SN notre rapport souligne
qu'en 2022 la sûreté des installations
nucléaires ainsi que la radioprotection
dans les secteurs industriels médicales
du transport des matières nucléaires
à un niveau satisfaisant
même si cela ne constitue pas en soi un
indicateur absolu et qu'il faut rester
prudent on peut noter que le nombre
d'événements significatifs de niveau 1
et 2 classés à l'échelle Inès pour les
installations nucléaires étant baisse
depuis quatre ans avec 97 événements en
2022 contre par exemple 115 en 2019
aucun événement de niveau 2 n'a été
déclaré en 2022 sur les installations
l'année dernière il est précédente
pardon il y en avait eu un
les événements significatifs dans les
domaines médicaux et du transport des
matières radioactives reste extrêmement
faibles au regard du nombre d'actes et
de transports qui sont réalisés
les examens de sûreté conduit tous les
10 ans sont menés de manière globalement
satisfaisante par tous les exploitants
ce qui permet de faire progresser le
niveau de sûreté et de radioprotection
des installations
voilà les premiers constats nous pouvons
tirer de manière globale et ses constats
sont donc positifs dans un contexte
marqué par plusieurs aléas et par des
fragilités qui persistent
aussi j'en viens aux trois points
d'attention tout d'abord l'année 2022 a
été marquée par des aléas sur les
installations nucléaires jamais
rencontré jusqu'à lors ces événements
qui peuvent être illustrés par le nombre
et la durée des arrêts de réacteurs
d'EDF sans précédent durant l'hiver
2022-2023 et par les fragilités
persistantes dans les installations du
cycle combustible
confirme l'importance de disposer de
marge pour la sûreté et d'anticiper les
enjeux dans un système nucléaire
interdépendant dans lequel les aléas sur
certaines installations peuvent avoir
des conséquences sur le fonctionnement
des autres et ou un Alena un aléa
générique est toujours possible
dans ce contexte et c'est le premier
point d'attention
la snstime qu'un travail de sécurisation
industrielle pour les 15 à 20 ans à
venir sur une partie significative des
installations actuelles à la fois des
réacteurs de puissance mais aussi les
installations du cycle du combustible
doit être anticipée dans le cadre de la
PPE pour éviter le risque d'un Pass au
sein du système nucléaire dans son
ensemble
ensuite et c'est mon second point
d'attention l'été 2022 a été marquée par
une canicule et une sécheresse d'une
rare intensité qui ont conduit l'ASM
pour la première fois depuis 2003 à
prendre des décisions exceptionnelles
permettant de déroger aux prescriptions
de rejet thermique et de maintenir en
fonctionnement cinq réacteurs
cette situation n'a pas eu de
conséquence sur la sûreté nucléaire la
surveillance de l'environnement par
l'exploitant a été spécifiquement
renforcé pour être en mesure de détecter
au plus tôt une éventuelle dégradation
du milieu
pour l'ASM la gestion des conséquences
de ce type d'épisodes extrêmes dont la
fréquence pourrait augmenter dans les
années à venir nécessite une
consolidation des connaissances
scientifiques sur l'impact
environnemental cumulé des rejets ainsi
qu'une réflexion sur les évolutions
technologiques à intégrer dans les
installations ainsi que sur les
capacités d'adaptation des installations
à prévoir pour le nouveau nucléaire et
cela dans un cadre d'une approche
globale et de long terme
cette approche devra être menée avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes au
niveau des territoires et des bassins
versants
enfin ce sera mon troisième point
d'attention les résultats des contrôles
réalisés par la SN en 2022 montre que
les capacités techniques de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement nucléaire reste un
point de vigilance
ces dernières années l'ASM appelé
l'attention à plusieurs reprises sur la
nécessité de renforcer les capacités
d'investissement les compétences la
rigueur professionnelle et la qualité au
sein de la filière industrielle
depuis deux ans pour aller au-delà des
missions traditionnelles d'inspection
des exploitants et des fabricants et
dans la perspective du développement
d'un nouveau programme nucléaire l'ASN a
réalisé des contrôles par sondage dans
l'ensemble de la chaîne de
sous-traitance nucléaire et sur la
gestion de projets des exploitants le
retour d'expérience de l'année 2022
montre que des efforts importants
restent à réaliser en matière de
définition claire des exigences à
respecter de qualité et de rigueur dans
la chaîne d'approvisionnement
d'évaluation des capacités techniques
des prestataires ainsi qu'en matière de
prévention de détection et de traitement
des irrégularités dans la chaîne de
sous-traitance
dans ce contexte l'a SN souhaite que les
donneurs d'ordre de la filière renforce
significativement leur vigilance sur les
capacités à faire de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement au regard de
l'ampleur des nouveaux projets et des
installations en service
au-delà de ces éléments d'appréciation
et de ces trois points d'attention je
voudrais évoquer les principaux constats
par exploitants et par grand domaine
d'activité qui figure dans notre rapport
chez EDF la qualité d'exploitation des
centrales nucléaires s'est maintenu à un
niveau satisfaisant en 2022 toutefois
son amélioration pour les centrales qui
étaient en retrait par rapport aux
autres s'avère souvent plus long
qu'estimé cela a été le cas en 2022 pour
les centrales de Golfech et de
Gravelines et c'est le cas début 2023 de
la centrale de Dampierre
en 2022 l'exploitation du parc de
réacteur de EDF a été marqué par les
conséquences de la découverte d'un
phénomène de corrosion sous contrainte
sur les circuits raccordés au circuit
primaire
les actions engagées par EDF pour y
faire face ont été satisfaisantes sur le
plan de la sûreté
elles ont permis d'établir un diagnostic
des installations concernées de donner
des premières est explications du
phénomène
d'identifier les parties de circuit et
des soudures les plus sensibles et enfin
d'établir une stratégie priorisée de
contrôle et de réparation qui a été jugé
appropriée par la SN
cette stratégie a été récemment adaptée
au vu des derniers constats fait sur des
soudures réparées au moment de la
construction initiale avec de fortes
énergies de soudage nous pourrons je
pense y revenir lors des questions
reste très vigilante sur ce sujet elle
s'est impliquée particulièrement dans le
partage d'expérience sur ces phénomènes
de corrosion avec ces homologues
étrangers
en 2022 EDF a poursuivi les travaux en
vue de la mise en service de l'EPR de
Flamanville et notamment la
requalification de l'installation après
les modifications et les réparations qui
ont été effectuées
un travail important reste à faire en
amont de la mise en service pour
réaliser la dernière campagne d'essai
sur site et pour certifier la conformité
de certains équipements sous pression
nucléaire ainsi que pour justifier la
conception ou la performance de certains
équipements ou de systèmes importants
pour la sûreté à la demande de l'ASM EDF
a réalisé des analyses approfondies afin
d'identifier les causes des anomalies
affectant le combustible et le cœur qui
ont été conçus
les opère à l'étranger et notamment à
taille Chan et on a tiré les
enseignements pour la mise en service de
l'EPR de Flamanville
concernant les projets d'EDF dans le
domaine des petits réacteurs modulaires
les SMS l'année 2022 a été marquée par
les travaux préliminaires d'évaluation
de sûreté du réacteur new Ward à
l'initiative de la s.n les autorités de
sûreté française finlandaise et tchèque
ont engagé de manière conjointe l'examen
préliminaire des principales options de
sûreté de ce projet ce travail
débouchera cet été sur une déclaration
commune
pour l'ASN ce type d'initiative concrète
de coopération multilatérales sur des
conceptions de réacteurs à maturité
suffisante constitue une étape
indispensable pour une meilleure
convergence des exigences de sûreté
applicables au SMR au niveau
international
dans le domaine des SMS l'ASM a par
ailleurs poursuivi en 2022 ces échanges
avec plusieurs entreprises françaises ou
étrangères développant des projets de
différentes technologies à l'instar de
ces homologues le travail réalisé tantôt
niveau national international exige un
renforcement substantiel des moyens de
l'ASM
le développement des SMS conduira à une
plus grande diversité des acteurs et des
technologies à maîtriser
voilà pour EDF et les réacteurs
nucléaires
concernant Orano la SN considère que le
niveau de sûreté des installations a été
globalement satisfaisant en 2022 dans la
continuité des années précédentes
plusieurs projets industriels importants
pour la sûreté et la radioprotection ont
été menées à leur terme comme la
construction de nouveaux évaporateurs
dans l'usine de La Hague et la mise en
place de nouvelles capacités
d'entreposage de matière et de déchets à
la Hague ou au Tricastin
s'agissant de l'usine de Melox l'ASN
considère que le niveau de sûreté
satisfaisant mais reste particulièrement
vigilante sur la radioprotection du fait
de l'augmentation des interventions
liées à la maintenance qui sont
nécessaires pour accroître la
disponibilité de l'installation et
sécuriser le cycle du combustible
malgré des avancées en 2022 la SN
considère que le fonctionnement du cycle
du combustible qui repose sur un
ensemble d'installations dont chacune
est souvent un maillon unique dans une
chaîne de traitement présente toujours
très peu de marge
l'ASN insiste une nouvelle fois sur la
nécessité de renforcer les démarches
d'anticipation ainsi que la qualité des
études afin de pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
dans les temps les dispositions
nécessaires pour prévenir les risques de
situation bloquantes pour le cycle du
combustible et pour la production de
l'électricité nucléaire
c'est le cas par exemple pour les
projets de nouvelles capacités
d'entreposage de matières plus tonifères
et des parades à mettre en place en vue
de pallier le retard constaté sur le
projet de piscine centralisée
d'entreposage des combustibles usés qui
est porté par EDF
de manière générale la SN considère
Coran no doit approfondir le travail
qu'il a démarré de revues des enjeux
associés au vieillissement de l'ensemble
des installations sur le site de La
Hague afin de dresser un état général du
site et de conforter les perspectives
d'exploitation de ces différents
ateliers dans des conditions sûrs
jusqu'à l'horizon 2040 actuellement
envisagée dans la PPE
pour ce qui concerne les installations
nucléaires exploitées par le CEA qui
sont en grande majorité concernées par
des opérations de démantèlement et de
gestion des matières et des déchets
radioactifs la SN considère que la
sûreté de ces installations reste
maîtrisées notamment grâce à la mise en
oeuvre des grands engagements de sûreté
pris au plus haut niveau du CEA
sur la période 2019-2022 la SN constate
que la stratégie priorisée de
démantèlement et de gestion des matières
et des déchets définis par le CEA
approuvé par la SN en 2019 produit des
résultats positifs
néanmoins la SN identifie la forte vu la
réhabilité de certains projets
importants en raison de deux principaux
facteurs la gestion des contrats avec
des difficultés contractuelles sur des
opérations prioritaires pour la sûreté
et le caractère unique de quelques
installations clés d'entreposage ou de
gestion des effluents dont dépend plus
ou moins tous les projets
de manière transversale et pour les deux
exploitants que sont le CEA et Orano
l'ASN estime que les opérations
stratégiques de démantèlement et de
reprise et de conditionnement des
déchets anciens exigent une meilleure
lisibilité et un meilleur suivi de la
maturité des phases de projets qui les
concernent ces opérations sont complexes
et s'étendent en général sur plusieurs
décennies
dans son rapport 2022 la SN présente
pour la première fois un observatoire de
démantèlement et de reprise et de
conditionnement des déchets pour les
projets prioritaires ces projets feront
désormais l'objet d'une démarche
spécifique et transparente de suivi par
phase pardon par phase ou par jalon de
projet
pour terminer avec les exploitants
nucléaires concernant l'endra dans les
installations sont exploitées de manière
satisfaisante en matière de sûreté de
Radioprotection et de protection de
l'environnement le fait marquant et le
dépôt en 2023 de la demande
d'autorisation de création de 6 Go
les modalités
d'instructions de cette demande qui
s'étalera sur une période d'au moins
trois ans ont été définis en 2022 en
liaison avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et le Haut Comité pour la
transparence et l'information sur la
sécurité nucléaire elle permettront de
prendre en compte toutes les questions
techniques qui suscitent des attentes à
chacune des étapes du processus
d'instruction
je terminerai mon propos liminaire par
les principales appréciations de la SN
sur les activités nucléaires dans les
domaines médicaux industriels et du
transport des matières radioactives
dans ces domaines en 2022 le niveau de
sûreté de radioprotection c'est maintenu
à un niveau satisfaisant
dans le domaine médical la forte tension
en particulier sur les moyens humains à
conduit à la mise en place de nouvelles
organisations de travail notamment
multicites ou faisant appel à des
intervenants extérieurs en 2022 la SN a
été particulièrement vigilante à ce que
ces nouvelles organisations engendrent
pas un recul de la radioprotection
les observations tirées des inspections
de la SN ces dernières années montrent
que la culture de la radioprotection
reste perfectible dans le domaine des
pratiques interventionnelles radio
guidées pour lesquelles la formation des
personnels à la radioprotection des
patients et des travailleurs peine à
progresser
les événements significatifs de
radioprotection restent dans la
continuité par rapport aux années
précédentes et restent très faible en
volume comparé au nombre d'actes
réalisés toutefois la répartition de la
répétition pardon de certains événements
montrent que le retour d'expérience
d'événements anciens et parfois oubliés
ainsi des erreurs d'étalonnage en
radiothérapie externe ont été de nouveau
révélés en 2022 malgré l'existence
d'événements similaires ayant fait
l'objet de fiches de retour d'expérience
de la SN qui avait été partagée au sein
de la profession
ce constat existe dans d'autres domaines
comme celui de la gammagraphie
industrielle où ont été constatés à
nouveau des mauvaises pratiques dans la
gestion de situation de blocage de
source ces événements nous rappellent
que la culture de radioprotection n'est
jamais acquise mais doit être entretenu
de manière générale la SN promeut toutes
les actions susceptibles de concourir à
la mise en oeuvre des principes de
justification et d'optimisation
à ce titre dans le domaine médical la
SNA insisté sur l'importance et la
plus-value des audits cliniques externes
par les Pères et soutient leur mise en
place en particulier en radiothérapie et
scanographie la part importante des
traitements par radiothérapie en
oncologie et l'amélioration de la survie
des patients rendent d'autant plus
importante l'évaluation des effets radio
induits à long terme
la SN rappelle ainsi dans son rapport la
nécessité de la mise en place de
registre de suivi des patients ayant
bénéficié de traitement par
radiothérapie pour permettre une
meilleure évaluation de leurs effets
radio induits à long terme en
particulier pour les nouvelles pratiques
comme lipo fractionnement ou la flash
thérapie par exemple
enfin pour terminer dans le domaine du
transport des substances radioactives la
SN estime que le niveau de sûreté de
radioprotection est resté globalement
satisfaisant si des incidents routiers
en particulier ont affecté quelques
transports et sont en nombre très très
faible un pour 10000 au regard des 770
000 transports réalisés chaque année
voilà monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires les points du rapport de
2022 de l'ASM que je souhaitais
souligner et si vous le permettez je
passe la parole à Olivier gutta pour ce
pour terminer ses propos liminaires
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le vice-président
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
je voudrais pour ma part vous parler des
conséquences sur les sûreté nucléaires
et sont contrôles de ce que nous avons
vécu depuis un peu plus d'un an c'est à
dire une crise énergétique à l'échelle
européenne
une accélération des programmes
nucléaires dans plusieurs pays et une
guerre en Ukraine qui questionne à
l'évidence la sûreté des installations
nucléaires en cas de conflit
alors d'abord cette crise énergétique en
Europe
l'appelle selon nous une vigilance
collective en matière de sûreté
nucléaire en particulier parce qu'elle
conduit les pays à revoir parfois assez
substantiellement leur politique
énergétique et cela se traduit dans le
domaine nucléaire par des projets
nouveaux par un accroissement fort et
assez peu anticipé aussi de la charge de
travail et cela s'accompagne également
du souhait que tous ces projets avancent
vite
or le nucléaire étant plutôt le domaine
du temps long il y a un risque que cette
situation mette en tension les
industriels et les autorités de contrôle
au détriment de la qualité de
réalisation des projets et de la sûreté
d'où cette nécessité de vigilance
vigilance collective parce que pour
reprendre une expression utilisée par un
ancien président de la SN la sûreté
nucléaire est un bien commun
alors nous avons discuté cette question
au sein de l'association des
responsables de d'autorité de sûreté
d'Europe oùenra et nous avons dans une
déclaration commune émie plusieurs
recommandations pour limiter ce risque
de mise en tension
première recommandation les décisions de
politique énergétique doivent tenir
compte des délais de réalisation des
projets industriels et donc être prise
avec suffisamment d'anticipation
elle doit aussi autant que possible être
stables dans le temps et ces deux
éléments sont importants parce que
l'absence de visibilité et l'absence de
stabilité sont préjudiciables à la
sûreté
notre deuxième recommandation c'est de
respecter la responsabilité première des
exploitants en matière de conduite des
projets et de sûreté
en particulier c'est à eux exploitant de
gérer leur planning en tenant compte du
temps nécessaire pour bâtir des
démonstrations de sûreté de bonne
qualité et en tenant compte aussi du
temps nécessaire à leur instruction
la troisième recommandation s'adresse à
nous-mêmes en quelque sorte autorité de
sûreté nous devons travailler de façon
efficace proportionnée aux enjeux et
rendre compte et rendre nos décisions
dans les délais
donc vous le voyez au fond nous ne
faisons que rappeler le rôle de chacun
au bénéfice de la sûreté mais c'était
important effectivement que chacun
assume jusqu'au bout ses responsabilités
deuxième point de mon intervention
nous-mêmes et nos homologues devront
réfléchir à la manière d'aborder cette
terre nouvelle d'accélération des
programmes nucléaires c'est le cas en
France mais c'est à l'évidence le cas
dans beaucoup de pays
est-ce que nos méthodes de contrôle sont
adaptées à une charge de travail en
croissance rapide
comment préparons-nous préparons-nous à
l'examen de technologie innovante
est-ce que nos exigences sont bien
proportionnées aux enjeux
et en particulier cette question en fait
ton trop ou trop peu en matière de
sûreté revient régulièrement et elle est
légitime alors comment procédons-nous
finalement pour fixer notre niveau
d'exigence et bien nous cherchons à
dégager un juste équilibre dans nos
décisions par un dialogue technique très
approfondie avec les industriels au
cours duquel nous examinons les
possibilités d'amélioration de la sûreté
en tenant compte comme on dit de l'état
de l'art c'est à dire de ce qui se fait
couramment dans le domaine considéré et
y compris en regardant ce qui se fait à
l'étranger et ceux qui ont décidé nos
homologues sur des cas similaires
le dialogue porte non seulement sur les
questions de sûreté de radio protoc de
Radioprotection et de protection de
l'environnement mais aussi sur la
faisabilité technique et industrielle
ainsi que sur les délais de mise en
oeuvre et c'est comme cela à l'issue de
ce dialogue que nous définissons et
objectivons ce qui est raisonnablement
possible
j'ajoute que sur les sujets les plus
importants nous ne travaillons pas seul
évidemment nous prenons la vie de nos
groupes permanents d'experts avis qui
sont rendus publics et nous organisons
également des consultations publiques
sur nos projets de décision pour que
toutes les personnes qui veulent
s'exprimer puissent le faire
alors maintenant sommes-nous prêts à
faire face à ce nouveau contexte que
j'évoquais
je voudrais vous donner deux exemples
d'évolution que nous mettons en place
pour nous adapter justement à la relance
du nucléaire
relance qui n'est pas seulement
quantitative avec des réacteurs
identiques à ceux que l'on connaît
exploiter par le seul EDF mais aussi
qualitative d'une certaine façon avec de
nouvelles technologies de nouveaux
industriels entrants et des compétences
à reconstituer
premier exemple nous sommes en train de
monter une équipe en charge du contrôle
des petits réacteurs modulaires avancés
et nous mettons en place des méthodes de
travail adaptées à la nature de ces
projets et aux spécificités surtout des
porteurs de projets qui sont pour
l'essentiel les startups qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de travailler avec nous donc
ça nécessite à évidence des adaptations
par rapport à ce que nous faisions avec
les gros industriels que nous contrôler
le long jusqu'à présent
deuxième exemple nous montons en
capacité en expérience sur le contrôle
et l'inspection du tissu industriel de
fournisseur contenu de leur rôle dans la
qualité des fabrications et c'est
notamment sur la base des conclusions de
ces nouvelles inspections que Bernard de
Rosu qui a pu s'exprimer sur ce point
voilà donc en résumé dans le contexte
actuel de relance du nucléaire il paraît
essentiel de disposer d'un contrôle
indépendant reposant sur un personnel
compétent fondé c'est vraiment essentiel
sur le dialogue technique et sachant
s'adapter aux nouveaux enjeux
je voudrais terminer mon propos par
quelques mots sur les conséquences en
matière de sûreté nucléaire de la guerre
en Ukraine
bien sûr il faudra attendre la fin du
conflit pour en tirer toutes les leçons
y compris au plan de la sûreté mais on
peut déjà retenir je crois trois
enseignements
d'abord les combats qui ont eu lieu
autour de la centrale de zaporiggia en
particulier
ont montré tout l'intérêt des
améliorations de sûreté décidé à
l'échelle européenne à la suite de
l'accident de Fukushima je pense par
exemple
groupe électrogène diesel supplémentaire
qui ont été installés donc comme le son
tiré de de l'accident de Fukushima et
qui ont placé cette centrale dans une
bien meilleure situation pour faire face
aux pertes d'alimentation électrique
externe répétée qu'elle a subi y compris
encore ces jours derniers
ensuite les conséquences de la guerre je
crois qu'il faut toujours garder ça à
l'esprit ce ne sont pas seulement des
dégâts matériels ou des conséquences
matérielles sur les sur les
installations ce sont aussi des
perturbations de la logistique mais
aussi je dirais même surtout une
désorganisation des équipes un stress
permanent pour les opérateurs
tous les sujets finalement qu'on
regroupe sur le sous le vocable facteur
humain et organisationnel
et ces aspects restent aujourd'hui avec
la prise de contrôle par les Russes de
la centrale de zapporigia il y a
plusieurs mois un facteur de
fragilisation de la sûreté
enfin troisième enseignement il était
essentiel que dans une telle situation
les autorités de sûreté travaillent
ensemble à l'échelle européenne et c'est
ce que nous avons fait nous avons
partagé nos évaluations nous avons
comparé nos simulations en cas
d'accident nucléaire en Ukraine et sur
ces bases l'association Wayra a publié
plusieurs analyses sur laquelle sur
lesquels ensuite chacun d'entre nous a
pu s'appuyer pour délivrer à ces médias
nationaux une information cohérente à
l'échelle européenne
par exemple au début du conflit alors
que dans beaucoup de pays une partie de
la population cherchait à se procurer
des comprimésdiodes nous avons rappelé
que en cas d'accident y compris avec
fusion du cœur l'ordre de grandeur des
rayons de prise diode pouvait alors
selon le scénario aller jusqu'à 20 km
voire 100 km mais pas très au-delà et le
fait de pouvoir dire cela sur la base
d'un consensus européen a été
extrêmement utile
et nous aurons naturellement à coeur de
continuer de nous coordonner entre
autorité de sûreté européenne chaque
fois que nécessaire
voilà monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires ce dont je souhaitais
vous faire part et je vous remercie de
votre attention nous sommes prêts
maintenant à répondre à vos questions
je vous remercie
tous les deux pour la présentation de ce
rapport annuel et des enjeux qui ont
pu s'effectuer au cours de l'année 2022
et je me réjouis de la façon rigoureuse
dont l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
sur l'ensemble de ces missions auprès à
la fois des parlementaires comme de
l'ensemble des acteurs du de la filière
nucléaire je vous propose de passer à
l'ordre des questions réponses avec
peut-être monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président une intervention de votre
part si vous souhaitez commencer la
phase de ces questions
parcours choisi pour mes les membres de
l'office qui ont fait l'effort de venir
et je les en remercie je souhaite leur
donner la parole d'abord ils connaissent
parfaitement les sujets j'ai toute une
batterie de questions en effet
bien écoutez je passe donc la parole à
Stéphane pinoir pour la première
question
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Vice-Président merci de votre
courtoisie on va on va en profiter je
remercie évidemment monsieur le
Président de la SN du directeur général
salut aussi les les membres du collège
qui sont tous présents aujourd'hui pour
cette présentation du rapport qui est un
temps annuel que nous attendons avec
nous pas avec impatience mais avec la
rigueur nécessaire
conféré à ce type d'exercice
et il faut bien dire que peut-être que
cette année cet exercice revêt un
caractère un petit peu particulier
compte tenu disons du focus un petit peu
différent des années précédentes qui est
désormais porté sur l'activité nucléaire
sur l'industrie nucléaire et son
organisation à l'intérieur de notre pays
d'abord ce focus il est il faut bien le
dire quand même
motivé par des intentions
gouvernementales qui pour dire les
choses de manière assez sobre ont un
tout petit peu évolué par rapport au
mandat précédent par rapport au Canada
précédent et donc qui relance la
question du nucléaire sur pour notre
pays et plus largement vous l'avez dit
directeur général en Europe puisque on a
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on a un mouvement
de pays européens qui se posent à
nouveau la question du nucléaire ou qui
se la pose pour la première fois
d'ailleurs pour certains sur leur sur
leur sol mais ce focus il est aussi
alimenté par les difficultés qui ont été
rencontrées durant l'année 2022 ça a été
dit la sécheresse la canicule qui pose
des questions et le sujet aujourd'hui
une pas question d'être pro ou
antinucléaire c'est de se dire est-ce
que toutes les conditions sont réunies
pour une exploitation optimale de nos
réacteurs désormais de nos 56 réacteurs
sur notre sol en tenant compte des
événements majeurs que nous avons
rencontrés la canicule et la sécheresse
mais aussi évidemment les phénomènes de
corrosion sous contrainte et je pense
que la France a vraiment un rôle à jouer
c'est le cas aussi de la ministre bannir
une rôle à jouer de leader rôle qu'elle
avait pendant les décennies et donc on
va être très attentif à cette à ce
mouvement on peut donc se féliciter pour
finir sur ce point féliciter qu'une
autorité indépendante comme la SN puisse
effectuer des des contrôles et prendre
des décisions collégiales faut-il le
rappeler c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans
ce rapport ça ne dépend pas d'un seul
homme mais bien de 5 personnes avec
potentiellement je le suppose en tout
cas des avis qui sont qui peuvent être
contradictoires
première question c'est compte tenu de
ces événements majeurs qui sont survenus
de l'année dernière est-ce que ça a
modifié ce que ça a des conséquences sur
la doctrine d'examen des installations
de la part de la SN on sait bien que le
phénomène de corrosion sous contrainte
pour le dire comme ça a été découvert un
petit peu par hasard en tout cas il
était totalement inattendu est-ce que ça
change le l'algorithme de contrôle des
installations éventuellement à des
endroits qu'on n'avait pas sur
l'ensemble de la chaîne qu'on avait pas
l'habitude de contrôler en tout cas pour
de cette façon là et par conséquent
est-ce que ça pose la question des
moyens supplémentaires nous sommes
parlementaires et à l'automne nous
aurons évidemment un examen du budget à
envisager est-ce que ça se traduit par
des moyens des demandes de moyens
supplémentaires je pense aussi dans
l'augmentation des missions à la SN
aux nouvelles technologies et aux SMS on
parle beaucoup des SMS mais il pas que
ça si jamais ces SMR venait à être
implanté à différents sites de notre
territoire
quels impacts quelles conséquences
concrètes en termes de dispersion de la
technologie nucléaire ça
comme conséquence est-ce que
est-ce que vous êtes je sais pas si vous
pouvez prononcer là-dessus mais
favorable ou plutôt réticent à cette
dispersion vous avez parlé du cycle de
combustible alors je suis à titre
personnel parce que j'ai mené des
travaux sur ce sujet là au sujet
d'Astrid très attaché au cycle du
combustible qui selon la loi de 2006 qui
a vu la création de la SN si je ne
m'abuse inscrit aussi dans dans la loi
le cycle fermé
qui comprend donc parce que ma
connaissance c'est la solitude les
réacteurs à neutrons rapides et il se
trouve que depuis bientôt 4 ans
maintenant le l'État français a décidé
de mettre
on va dire en sommeil sinon à on arrête
total c'est cette ce projet Astrid qui
avait vocation à déboucher sur des
réacteurs à neutrons rapides à l'horizon
2040 et puis pour finir
un sujet de communication moi je j'ai le
tableau là des des incidents qui ont été
relevés pendant l'année 2022 vous l'avez
dit on est sur les installations
nucléaires de base on est rendu à 2017
c'est-à-dire qu'on est tombé en dessous
du nombre d'incidents observés en 2017
aucun de niveau 2 l'an dernier et
pourtant c'est un petit peu comme la
fumée qui s'échappe des réacteurs
nucléaires et une croyance populaire qui
veut que ce soit du CO2 au lieu de la
vapeur d'eau et pourtant dans l'opinion
publique il y a à chaque fois qu'il y a
un incident de niveau 1 une comment dire
un petit peu d'agitation autour de ça
est-ce que vous avez une réflexion au
sein de la SN pour avoir une
communication plus large qui permettrait
de rassurer notre population voilà je
vous remercie
madame Marie
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président pour cette
exposé extrêmement complet et les
documents qui y sont joints alors au
regard de l'ensemble des alertes que
vous avez appelé point d'attention mais
que moi j'appelle alerte donc vous ne
faites pas j'avoue ne pas comprendre ou
en tout cas de moins en moins comment il
est possible dans l'état de la
connaissance et des évolutions dont ils
viennent être fait état de s'engager à
nouveau dans une hôtel aventure
parce que son décrite et elles sont
extrêmement bien décrites dans le
document que vous nous avez communiqué
les plus grandes difficultés à venir
alors l'instabilité politique que vous
en avez fait état et les problèmes de
sûreté l'instabilité politique qui
conduit effectivement à complexifier
l'accès également à la ressource
les enjeux de réparation des
installations actuelles
corrosion de souffrance les enjeux de
démantèlement qui ne sont toujours pas
maîtrisés ainsi que évidemment la
question de retraitement des déchets
que vous avez fait peu état mais qui
sont évidemment
indiqués dans votre dans votre rapport
et enfin enfin l'enjeu en lien avec le
dérèglement climatique alors à l'heure
où on nous dit qu'il faut se préparer à
+4 degrés et que je lis dans un contexte
où nous sommes pas encore à 1,5 mais
quasiment que vous avez été conduit
alors je prends mes lunettes excusez-moi
que après examen des enjeux liés à la
protection de l'environnement la SN
adopté successivement quatre décisions
fixant des prescriptions temporaires
relatives ou rejets thermiques des
centrales nucléaires de Golfech budget
Saint-Alban blaguer Tricastin allant
d'une période au 15 juillet au 11
septembre etc etc et donc je me dis dans
un contexte où même aujourd'hui dans
nous sommes début du printemps et
certaines régions sont déjà en état
grave de sécheresse j'imagine que vous
avez certainement eu fait des modèles
qui vous permettent de savoir de quelle
façon vous allez traiter dans l'avenir
si c'est phénomène se renouvelaient
alors avez-vous ce type de modélisation
et si oui pourriez-vous nous les
communiquer parce que ce qui relèvent de
l'exceptionnel s'il doit se renouveler
tous les ans n'est plus de
l'exceptionnel mais du conjoncturel et
donc quelle mesure à ce moment-là vous
seriez contraint de prendre
parce que vous ne pourriez plus
réchauffer refroidir pardon vos
centrales les réchauffements on les a
déjà je vous remercie
Jean-Luc Fuji
merci monsieur le Président je vais
faire assez enfin aller rapidement vers
les questions je m'associe complètement
ce qui a été dit par mon collègue
Stéphane pinoir sur les remerciements
qu'on vous a vous adresse pour la
qualité du travail qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui tout ce qui est réalisé au
service donc de la sûreté nucléaire dans
notre pays
Stéphane peignoir collègue a aussi
abordé un salon de sujets je voulais pas
penser à insister mais je voulais
revenir sur un petit peu les les
conséquences donc qu'à la
l'actualité je dirais sur sur les
travaux de la SN actuel et à venir et
notamment
je pense entre autres au fait que on a
26 de 6000 chiffres on était pas bon de
56 réacteurs de ce pays qui en 2035
arriveront à
cinquantaine et
la cinquantaine ça veut dire 50 ans
d'exploitations ça veut dire sûrement un
suivi renforcé en tout cas c'est une
question je vous pose et c'est aussi
voir comment on anticipe l'organisation
en termes de suivi vous avez beaucoup
parlé des uns les autres de l'adaptation
aux évolutions climatiques donc je
voudrais pas de questions là-dessus sauf
si vous jugez avoir des précisions à
nous apporter mais j'imagine aussi que
il y a des réflexions et je voulais
savoir un petit peu comment on
s'organise quand aujourd'hui on voit
poindre de nouveaux types de réacteurs
on parle de micro alors par exemple un
micro générateur donc nucléaire qui
utilise des déchets de très longue vie
ce type de technologie qui apparaissent
j'imagine que tout ceci peut avoir des
des conséquences sur comment s'organise
donc la SN pour suivre je dirais tous
ces sujets émergents en termes de
nouveaux de nouveaux de nouveaux
réacteurs possibles et donc derrière
viennent un petit peu la question aussi
globalement finalement des ressources
humaines en termes à la fois de quantité
mais aussi peut-être de formation et le
lien aussi c'est avec le futur est-ce
que aujourd'hui vous jugez que
on a suffisamment d'attractivité pour
pouvoir assurer des recrutements au
niveau de de scène et aussi un terme de
formation et puis aussi quid de la
formation tout au long de la vie la
fameuse formation continue des agents
actuels de la SN j'aimerais bien savoir
un peu plus sur le sujet autre question
vous avez évoqué monsieur le Président
tout à l'heure le la question de
l'Observatoire pour le démantèlement
si j'ai bien compris mais j'ai peut-être
pas tout eu le temps de tout analyser à
ce stade bien entendu mais je redresse
ça avec intérêt vous avez dit qu'il y
avait une première un petit peu pour
donc suivre ce démantèlement et les
premières observations donc première
mise en place cette observatoire
j'aimerais bien que vous puissiez nous
préciser quels sont les perspectives de
déploiement de cette observatoire que
vous envisagez parce que la question du
démantèlement nécessite un effet un
véritable suivi et peut-être aussi
qu'elle doit être plus c'est mieux
comprise et partager au niveau de de la
population pour qu'on voit un petit peu
comment ça se
s'organise comment ça se passe en fin
dernier point
on voit vous avez évoqué rapidement les
relations européennes ou j'allais dire
internationale mais surtout européenne à
travers winerat si je prononce bien le
terme et je me disais
au fond aujourd'hui on voit point de rue
une alliance on a parlé ces dernières
semaines d'une alliance autour du
nucléaire donc dans la France est plus
ou moins chef de fil avec 16 pays qui
qui semblent donc vouloir ou rentrer
dans le nucléaire ou le renforcer ou en
tout cas sur un maintien de leur voilà
de leur utilisation de de d'une de ces
trois formes majeures d'énergie avec les
fossiles et les renouvelables que sur
lequel est le nucléaire et je me disais
est-ce que
il y a des sujets émergents là aussi que
à votre niveau vous allez partager ou
que vous partagez d'ores et déjà avec
ces pays-là parce que justement il y a
peut-être
la nécessité de mettre en commun à la
fois l'expertise et toutes les
connaissances des uns et des autres pour
faire face et peut-être pour s'organiser
face à cette à cette montée en puissance
qui semble prendre
au niveau européenne en tout cas autour
de la question du nucléaire notamment
dans la dans la contribution que le
nucléaire peut constituer indépendamment
des positions politiques des uns et des
autres donc on peut constater que
l'utilisation nucléaire pour participer
à la sortie progressive des énergies
fossiles et quelque chose qu'il faut
considérer avec une grande intention et
peut-être faut-il aussi voir au niveau
européen c'est qu'il se passe et comment
la SN et les institutions équivalentes
dans les autres pays s'organisent pour
justement faire face à tous les sujets
émergents que cela sous-entend voilà un
petit peu ce que je voulais mettre en
avant et je serais ravi d'écouter vos
réponses
la parole est arrangé de Préville merci
monsieur le Président donc d'abord tout
d'abord merci pour tout le travail que
vous faites puisque nous pouvons tous
les Français vous être reconnaissants du
fait que nous n'ayons pas eu d'accident
nucléaires en France et moi je vais me
focaliser sur deux petites choses qui
m'ont interpellé lors de votre
présentation et la première sur c'est
sur le site de lag vous avez mentionné
qui doit y avoir une vigilance en ce qui
concerne la réalisation des contrôles
périodiques et la gestion des écarts et
que les mesures destinées à lutter
contre les effets du vieillissement
c'est ce qui m'a interpellé des
équipements des installations dont
certaines approches d'une durée
d'exploitation de 40 ans où le
remplacement par nouveaux équipements
constituent toujours un enjeu majeur
pour la poursuite de leur fonctionnement
sûr donc quels sont les conséquences de
ce vieillissement
quels sont les coûts les installations
nécessaires
parce que là j'arrive pas à mesurer ce
qui sera nécessaire de faire puisque
effectivement on est déjà à 40 ans pour
ses installations à la Hague et une
deuxième chose qui m'a interpellé c'est
en médecine nucléaire vous mentionnez
que des améliorations sont nécessaires
alors notamment sur la gestion des
effluents pour maîtriser les rejets dans
les réseaux d'assainissement donc est-ce
que vous pouvez apporter quelques
petites
[Musique]
des précisions sur en quoi ça consiste
je ne vois pas trop et évidemment ce qui
m'a un petit peu choqué c'est dans
l'organisation de la physique médicale
juger insuffisante dans 20% des services
inspectés en 2022 notamment regard des
enjeux de radioprotection associées au
traitement thérapeutique comme vous
l'avez mentionné monsieur le Président
donc là 20% voilà je je me demande alors
vous l'avez vous le signaler le point de
vigilance qu'est-ce qui est attendu quel
est le
en général quand vous mentionnez ce
genre de choses est-ce que il y a des
réactions immédiates et comment on
pourra y remédier puisque on est
particulièrement en tension dans le
milieu médical je vous remercie
Président Monsieur le Directeur je vous
propose de répondre à ces questions
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci pour ces questions
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
alors je vais répondre à un certain
nombre d'entre elles mais je donnerai
également la parole de manière générale
sur la question des ressources humaines
qui revu à plusieurs reprises au
directeur général Olivier gutta je
passerai la parole à Pierre bois en ce
qui concerne l'Observatoire
des démantèlements et des déchets
je redonnerai la parole à Olivier sur la
partie whenra je prendrai moi-même la
parole sur la partie internationale hors
Europe et puis je demanderai à Géraldine
Pina de répondre sur les questions
médicales voilà je fais les annonces
telle manière à ce que chacun puisse se
préparer
parfait alors première question monsieur
sénateur pied-noir vous nous dites à
fort juste titre est-ce que finalement
les événements assez hors normes
exceptionnels que nous avons souligné
nous ont conduit à faire évoluer notre
approche à la fois du contrôle nos
méthodes et nos compétences et je pense
que vous avez tout à fait raison de
souhaiter souligner pardon ce sujet
parce que nous avons face à nous des
enjeux qui sont tout à fait nouveau
notamment en termes de volume de
construction d'installation de valve si
elles sont décidées et en termes
d'évolution de structuration des acteurs
dans le domaine nucléaire alors nous
n'avons pas changé fondamentalement
notre doctrine puisque c'était la
question c'est à dire que nous sommes
toujours dans une relation de
approfondie de dialogue technique avec
les exploitants avec les fabricants en
vue d'organiser à la fois l'instruction
et le contrôle et nous les poussons je
dirais jusqu'au bout pour pouvoir bien
comprendre à la fois les sujets et
pouvoir
proportionné nos décisions aux enjeux
c'est extrêmement important cette idée
de proportionnalité et il peut y avoir
plein d'événements qui qui vous avez
évoqué les événements nombreux qui sont
parfois déclarés mais qui ne
correspondent très peu d'enjeux ou de
très faibles enjeux donc le but c'est
bien d'avoir un dialogue technique
approfondi pour bien comprendre les
sujets pour pouvoir challenger nos
interlocuteurs et pouvoir mettre nos
décisions en regard des enjeux pour la
sûreté la radioprotection donc cette
approche qui est d'un autre depuis
l'origine n'a pas changé en revanche le
champ dans lesquels nous la mettons en
œuvre à évoluer parce que nous avons
fait d'abord un retour d'expérience de
ce qui s'est passé ces dernières années
notamment sur les grands projets on
s'est aperçu que le fait d'avoir comme
interlocuteur l'exploitant final
était insuffisant pour avoir une bonne
idée de la qualité des réalisations
d'équipements qui ensuite seront
installés sur une installation et donc
nous nous sommes préoccupés d'aller voir
au-delà de l'exploitant et d'aller voir
dans la chaîne de fabrication qui est en
amont dans les sous-traitants de la
chaîne pour savoir s'il maîtrisait les
exigences qui sont nécessaires pour
assurer la qualité requise au nucléaire
donc on a élargi le champ et c'est sur
la base de ces constats fait dans un
champ plus large d'investigation que
nous tirons
en disant attention aux donneurs d'ordre
il y a des fragilités dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement donc on a élargi le
champ mais toujours avec la même qui est
d'approche de la même manière on s'est
aperçu que sur la gestion des projets
notamment de démantèlement ou de reprise
et de conditionnement des déchets
anciens c'est-à-dire les déchets qui
sont à l'origine du nucléaire qui ont
été entreposés dans les conditions de
l'époque mais ces conditions ne sont pas
satisfaisantes il faut et dans l'attente
d'une solution finale vers un stockage
définitif il faut reprendre leurs
conditionnement pour les reconditionner
dans des conditions plus sûrs nous avons
prescrit ces opérations mais on s'est
aperçu que la gestion de ces projets est
complexe et parfois des des phénomènes
qui étaient inattendus au moment de la
conception du projet apparaissait plus
tard et donc plutôt que d'être
uniquement en contrôle et en visibilité
à la fin du projet nous avons souhaité
nous intervenir dans la gestion même du
projet voir si l'opérateur gérait
correctement le projet de remise en état
de ces installations de démantèlement
donc il faut on a élargi le champ on est
plus exactement au même endroit on n'est
plus large mais avec la même philosophie
d'intervention donc ça suppose bien
évidemment des moyens de contrôle et des
moyens nouveaux d'investigation mais
Olivier parlera sur les sujets bien
évidemment les sujets des moyens
nouvelle technologie il y a un vrai défi
auquel on devons faire face dans les
médias c'est d'abord la numérisation il
faut que nous soyons en situation ce qui
n'était pas le cas auparavant d'avoir
une continuité numérique qui ne
continuité digitale avec les autres
acteurs qui nous fournissent un certain
nombre d'éléments sur lesquels nous il y
a ça d'ailleurs nous nous position dans
l'instruction ces échanges de données
informatisées sont aujourd'hui
indispensables et elles permettent
d'ailleurs ils permettent ces échanges
d'avoir une plus grande fiabilisation et
une meilleure traçabilité des opérations
de contrôle qui parfois sont des
opérations qui peuvent donner lieu à des
falsifications donc il y a un enjeu du
numérique qui est extrêmement important
avec également la mise en place par les
exploitants de jumeaux numériques qui
leur permettent d'avoir une meilleure
visibilité d'intervention sur les
installations d'abord dans la conception
puis ensuite dans les interventions ou
les intervenants peuvent répéter des
gestes à travers des visions 3D avant de
se retrouver sur site pour réaliser
leurs opérations et puis il y a bien sûr
le développement de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les opérations de
maintenance prises en compte par les
expats sur lesquels nous devons nous
interroger sur nos moyens de contrôle de
contrôle des algorithmes qui sont
utilisés nous voyons on est devant une
évolution technologique et considérable
et qui va demander de notre part de
nouvelles compétences des nouveaux
champs d'investigation et c'est
à travers ce sujet qu'il faut que nous
abordions le sujet de la compétence et
de l'expérience dans les années à venir
ce qui concerne le cycle du combustible
alors nous n'avons pas à vous le savez
nous avons émis un avis sur les options
de sûreté du projet Astrid mais nous
n'avons pas été impliqués dans le choix
de la mise à l'arrêt de ce réacteur de
expérimental nous avons en revanche pris
des positions sur le cycle du
combustible non pas sur la sa fermeture
d'ici on politique mais sur la fragilité
du cycle du combustible actuel qui
présente effectivement
sur certaines des installations
notamment l'installation Melox
l'installation certaines installations
de lag des fragilités qui pourraient
conduire à ce que cette ce cycle du
combustible soit momentanément
interrompu et si le cycle du combustible
est monumentanément interrompu c'est la
l'évacuation des combustibles usés des
centrales nucléaires qui ne peut plus
être opérée et donc c'est une fragilité
pour le système nucléaire dans son
ensemble donc nous sommes extrêmement
vigilants sur les installations du cycle
du combustible sur ces fragilités qui
vont nécessiter je reprendrai une autre
question qui a été posée sur le sujet en
termes de de d'anticipation sur les
enjeux à 50 ans et plus
vraisemblablement des rénovations
vraisemblablement un espace de grand
carénage sur les installations de lag
comme ça a été fait sur les
installations de DF pour pouvoir
poursuivre l'exploitation donc il y a
une fragilité sur le cycle du
combustible tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
prévu en ce qui concerne les décisions
politiques à prendre sur
le fermeture du cycle voir sur la
poursuite du retraitement des
combustibusés au-delà de 2040 ce n'est
pas une une un sujet qui pour la SN
concernant la communication autour des
des incidents ou des événements
significatifs je pense qu'il ne faut pas
se tromper bien évidemment on vit
nous-mêmes
les mois ou les réactions qui peuvent
que peuvent générer la publication de la
diffusion de constat un événement de
niveau 1 au niveau 2 qui ne présentent
pas toujours ni moins des engendrés en
termes de sûreté mais je pense que c'est
d'abord une transparence que nous devons
à la population qui est qui est
appréciée c'est un sujet qui permet
aussi à l'exploitant d'expliquer
notamment dans les commissions locales
d'information ce qui s'est passé donc ça
contribue également à une certaine
culture sur la sûreté alors il y a
toujours bien évidemment des montées en
épingle mais je pense que cette ce
travail d'explication autour des
événements est indispensable et nous
contribuons pour parler de la SN nous
contribuons à cette explication lors des
réunions des commissions locales
d'information
au cours desquelles l'exploitant vient
exposer les événements le nombre
d'événements significatifs n'est pas un
indicateur absolu ce n'est pas parce
qu'il augmente que il y a des risques ou
plus de problèmes en matière de sûreté
d'une certaine manière il vaut mieux que
il n'y ait pas une pression
indue qui soit faite sur le fait de
déclarer déclarer c'est être transparent
et c'est de se donner les moyens de
progresser et ça il faut le garder il
faut vraiment être vigilant là-dessus
pour ne pas avoir des effets induits sur
le l'examen de ces du nombre
d'indicateurs en revanche bien
évidemment le nombre global son
évolution peut être un signe de
meilleure maîtrise de la sûreté ou de la
radioprotection
madame heregui vous vous nous posez des
questions qui qui ne sont pas de notre
ressort en ce qui concerne les choix de
de politique énergétique
exercice qui existe qui se fait
régulièrement donc en termes de que
fait-on le processus est établi et le
fonctionnement il fonctionne tout à fait
correctement
le réchauffement climatique et la
l'élévation de la température
de l'air ou de l'eau ou
les étiages sévères bien évidemment ça
peut avoir à la fois des incidences en
termes de sûreté et avoir des incidences
en termes d'environnement sur les rues
les dispositions existent elles sont
encadrées et lorsqu'il est nécessaire il
peut y avoir ponctuellement et de
manière exceptionnelle des dérogations
qui sont octroyées dans des conditions
encadrées extrêmement encadrées en
matière de suivi de l'impact sur
l'environnement c'est ce que nous avons
fait en 2022 face à ce phénomène qui va
de toute façon se reproduire peut-être
ça s'amplifier nous souhaitons nous agir
à trois niveaux et à trois niveaux de
temporalité également dans l'immédiat il
faut cet avènement 2022 il faut en tirer
le retour d'expérience et il faut ce que
nous avons demandé à EDF que les étés
prochains s'étaient d'abord cette
vraisemblablement 2024 soit anticipé on
peut tirer un retour d'expérience sur
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en matière
d'impact environnemental parce que ça a
été mesuré donc il faut qu'on puisse
regarder ça de manière extrêmement
rapide pour pouvoir préparer les étés à
venir et faire en sorte que ce type de
situation soit réduit au strict minimum
ça c'est l'action de court terme
l'action de moyen terme qui peut être
entreprise c'est celle des millions
d'améliorer les installations par
elles-mêmes EDF a d'ailleurs annoncé
récemment qu'il envisageait par exemple
d'augmenter des capacités d'entreposage
des fluant pour pouvoir
les conserver ne pas les rejeter dans le
milieu lorsque le milieu ne peut pas les
accepter parce qu'il est pas il peut pas
les diluer par exemple donc ça c'est une
action qui peut être réalisée sur les
installations en service mais il y a
surtout un besoin de renforcement des
connaissances scientifiques pour
connaître comment en milieu réagit à des
rejets thermiques notamment pour pouvoir
recadrer si c'est nécessaire mais et si
c'est justifié les limites dans
lesquelles aujourd'hui les conditions de
rejet sont autorisées donc ça c'est un
travail qui ne peut reposer que sur une
meilleure connaissance scientifique des
de la situation ça ne va demander du
temps parce que les études sur la base
desquelles nous nous sommes appuyés pour
pouvoir encadrer les rejets des
installations date de plusieurs années
et il faut les reprendre ça c'est une
action à moyen terme des évolutions sur
les installations en service puis une
meilleure connaissance scientifique des
phénomènes sur le long terme la
réflexion elle doit être plus large elle
doit apporter sur les évolutions
technologiques il y a des installations
nucléaires dans des déserts
il y a pas en France bien sûr il y a des
installations
il y a des installations nucléaires pour
lesquelles des processus de
refroidissement avec des technologies
différentes de celles que nous utilisons
en France sont mises en place donc il
faut s'interroger sur ces technologies
si elles peuvent être mises en œuvre en
France sur les installations actuelles
ou sur les installations futures il y a
également des
intégrations à prévoir dans la
conception des nouveaux réacteurs les
nouveaux réacteurs PR2 sont des
réacteurs qui qui sauront s'ils sont mis
en place bien sûr
vraisemblablement au fonctionnement à la
fin de ce siècle les conditions
climatiques auront changé la fin de ce
siècle et donc dans la conception des ce
PA2 il faut envisager quels sont les
évolutions qui seraient possible ou qui
seraient nécessaires sur les
installations pendant toute cette
période de temps elles sont pas
forcément nécessaires tout de suite mais
elles seront nécessaires au fil du temps
et il faut avoir les capacités dans
l'installation de les intégrer je vais
prendre un exemple simple il y a une
question de sûreté qui est importante
c'est la température à l'intérieur du
bâtiment réacteur température qui est un
élément important pour faire fonctionner
les dispositifs de sûreté ils sont ils
ont des températures limites de
fonctionnement et bien il faut refroidir
le l'atmosphère au sein du bâtiment
reacteur en situation de canicule est-ce
que les opère 2 sont conçus pour pouvoir
être équipés de moyens de réfrigération
supplémentaire à travers le temps il
faut prévoir de l'espace pour pouvoir le
faire donc ce sont des anticipations qui
sont nécessaires pour pouvoir faire face
à ces événements et enfin je dirais que
tous ces sujets doivent être menés dans
le cadre d'une réflexion large qui
applique tous les acteurs notamment les
acteurs territoriaux et les acteurs des
bassins versants la ressource en eau est
partagée donc ce n'est pas uniquement le
sujet d'EDF il faut l'adresser avec
l'ensemble des acteurs d'un territoire
donc je pense que cette réflexion dont
l'EDF a bien conscience elle doit être
globale
et elle doit impliquer la totalité des
acteurs d'un territoire c'est ce que
nous avons demandé en distinguant très
nettement ces trois phases
monsieur fujite vous m'avez interrogé
sur les 50 ans et plus alors 50 ans et
plus c'est pour nous c'est vraiment un
sujet crucial nous ne faisons que
répéter d'année en année le besoin
urgent d'anticipation et il y a trois
niveaux en tout cas 3 3
moments d'anticipation 3 3 temporalités
d'anticipation selon nous
le premier le premier moment c'est celui
que j'évoquais dans mon dans mon
introduction luminaire c'est qu'est-ce
qui va se passer dans les 40 ans dans
les jusqu'en 2040 dans les 15 à 20 ans
qui viennent le premier horizon c'est de
maintenant à 2040 au vu des constats
faits sur les fragilités de certaines
installations la CS c'est les
installations du cycle combustible
il faut effectivement
se préoccuper dès à présent de la
sécurisation industrielle des
installations nucléaires c'était
également le sujet du vieillissement
oranolag envisage par exemple de dans le
cas du programme mais ça nous permet
aussi de répondre à la question qui
était posée à Madame par Madame Préville
c'est finalement quels sont les
évolutions à faire pour consolider le
fonctionnement de des installations et
il y a des points de faiblesse notamment
le poste de déchargement qui est un
point de faiblesse il va peut-être
falloir rénover il y a l'usine Melox
peut-être falloir faire quelque chose de
nouveau d'ici 2040 donc il y a un sujet
de première échéance d'ici
et d'ici 2040 nous devons également nous
positionner sur les points de faiblesse
très particuliers qui pourraient exister
sur le parc nucléaire en service c'est
un travail que nous sommes en train de
faire deuxième échéance c'est au-delà de
2040 pourquoi j'ai mis 2040 parce que
2040 c'est c'est les 60 ans c'est à dire
le parc nucléaire arrive à 60 ans et
2040 c'est ce qui est prévu aujourd'hui
dans la PPE pour le fonctionnement du
retraitement donc au delà de 2040 il y a
des décisions de fonds à prendre sur
est-ce que on envisage d'aller au-delà
de 60 ans de durée de vie des des
réacteurs nucléaires est-ce qu'on
envisage la poursuite ou pas du
retraitement et ça ça nécessite 15 ans
d'anticipation si le retraitement n'est
pas poursuivi il faut se préoccuper dès
à présent de la manière dont les
combustibles c'est seront entreposés
entreposage à sec comme quel sera quel
incident cela aura sur la le stockage
des déchets donc il y a bien des
décisions qui sont postes 20 40 qui
nécessitent elle elle également de
l'anticipation pour pouvoir faire face
et puis enfin il y a
l'anticipation à plus long terme que je
mettrai je dirais à horizon 2050 ou plus
de 2050
à cet horizontal les réacteurs les plus
anciens ont 70 ans ils étaient toujours
en service peut-être 80 ans
les réacteurs nucléaires on peut
toujours dans des conditions sûrs
envisager bien sûr de poursuivre aussi
si c'est d'assureté d'assurer son
exploitation mais la durée vie sera pas
infinie un moment donné
s'arrêtera
en tout cas pour le parc actuel donc il
faut anticiper d'une certaine manière
compte tenu compte tenu de la puissance
de la puissance installée que représente
ce parc il faut anticiper ce qui sera la
suite ou la manière de faire face à cet
effet falaise qui pourrait se produire
au delà de 2050 et il faut l'anticiper
de manière suffisante voilà il y a donc
ces trois niveaux d'anticipation qui qui
nous semblent très importants au dessus
des 50 ans
je vais laisser maintenant la parole
alors d'abord à Olivier
merci
Bernard sur les alors sur les questions
de contrôle et de moyens naturellement
enfin une large partie de notre travail
finalement c'est d'orienter le contrôle
sur les sujets
pertinents en fonction du contexte
et pour prendre cet exemple on a vécu
pendant 10 ans j'allais dire ce que
j'appelle une décennie post Fukushima
s'il y a une décennie où tous les
acteurs ont été très polarisés sur le
retour d'expérience attirer de cet
accident d'ailleurs André Le Lacoste
l'avait dit que ça prendrait 10 ans au
moment de l'accident et c'est
effectivement ce qui s'est passé
et aujourd'hui on est dans un contexte
tout à fait nouveau de relance du
nucléaire avec effectivement des
questions nouvelles qui se posent comme
le contrôle de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et de fournisseurs
on l'a évoqué et qui nous amène
effectivement enfin autre exemple le
contrôle des nouveaux réacteurs faire
des petits réacteurs modulaires des
réacteurs avancés et qui nous amènent
finalement à cibler autrement notre
contrôle la doctrine reste la même ça a
été rappelée mais les inspections les
dossiers qu'on examine les analyses
qu'on fait elles sont évidemment
adaptées aux enjeux nouveaux au contexte
nouveau
pour donner quelques ordres de grandeur
alors sur un sujet comme
de citer plusieurs exemples quand il y a
eu le sujet des fraudes Creusot on a
dédié une équipe de plusieurs personnes
sur le contrôle de ces questions sur le
contrôle des fournisseurs lors de
grandeur c'est aussi quelques personnes
sur la corrosion sous contrainte autre
exemple sujet qui s'est invité il y a un
an et demi et qui avait pas été anticipé
en termes de moyens c'est l'équivalent
de 5 et qui veut 25 personnes 5
équivalentes en plein qu'on a dû
consacrer à ce sujet et je peux donner
aussi notre ordre de grandeur on a
réalisé en 2022 une bonne quarantaine
d'inspection
sur ce sujet alors sur les réparations
de soudure sur les
les découpes qui étaient faites sur les
sur les tuyauteries etc enfin sur les
contrôles non destructifs sur tous les
sur toute la palette en fait d'activités
autour de autour de ce sujet
voilà et donc ça c'est c'est
effectivement des éléments qu'on
comprend compte dans l'estimation des
besoins alors au principal dans les
années à venir et en particulier dès
cette année quels sont les gros morceaux
si je puis dire qu'ils sont devant nous
bah on a d'abord reçu en début d'année
un énorme dossier qui est celui de 6Go
l'installation de de stockage profond de
déchets un dossier colossal alors qu'on
avait déjà commencé à instruire de
longue date avec londrame enfin là
maintenant c'est le le dossier
d'autorisation création en tant que tel
et donc forcément on va devoir consacrer
une partie de nos équipes à son examen
on attend là dans le courant du mois de
juin si selon nos informations le dépôt
d'un premier dossier sur sur EP R2 donc
à panli donc là aussi c'est pareil il va
falloir consacrer des moyens sachant que
on a déjà déjà commencé à contrôler des
des fabrications
tests on va dire qui ont été lancés sur
sur les gros composants des EPR 2 pour
effectivement commencer à qualifier les
méthodes de fabrication donc là aussi
c'est plusieurs plusieurs équivalentes
en plein qui va falloir dédier
j'évoquais le montage donc de cette
équipe sur les sur les nouveaux
réacteurs au total on a évalué nos
besoins pour l'année prochaine à 12 ETP
et sur les quatre ans qui viennent à une
trentaine alors évidemment on recale au
fur et à mesure des des
plannings des industriels par exemple on
aurait espéré pouvoir déployer des
moyens sur enfin qui sont aujourd'hui
consacrés au contrôle de flamand ville 3
et voilà donc qu'on a on attend la mise
en service pour pouvoir les réaffecter
sur d'autres
s voilà mais c'est ces ordres de
grandeur sont sont ceux là
en prolongement
monsieur le député Fuji avait une
question sur la formation des des
personnels de la SN alors nous recrutons
déjà à bon niveau on recrute au niveau
ingénieur
donc
j'allais dire bac + 5 enfin oui ou
équivalent on a aussi dans le même
médical bien entendu des médecins des
pharmaciens
on a aussi quelques universitaires donc
des personnels de formation scientifique
et de bon niveau pour autant on a un
dispositif de formation interne
extrêmement poussé et grosso modo la
première année en fonction à la SN
les nouveaux arrivants suivent des
stages sur l'équivalent mis bout à bout
de plusieurs mois et un dispositif de
compagnonnage qui leur permet finalement
de se former à l'inspection à
l'instruction des dossiers techniques
à
toutes les activités qui sont ceux des
inspecteurs et des charges d'affaires de
l'ASN et qui effectivement mobilisent
l'essentiel de la première année avant
effectivement qu'il gagne en autonomie
puisqu'on est sur des sujets dont la
complexité nécessite effectivement un
investissement important et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on souhaite que nos
personnels valorisent cet investissement
en restant
un temps suffisamment long en notre sein
on a aujourd'hui
pas de difficulté majeures de
recrutement dans la mesure où notre
visée principale
ce sont des corps de fonctionnaires il y
a pour autant un certain nombre de
j'allais dire de signaux d'alerte qui
nous qui nous préoccupe d'abord on
constate que de façon générale les corps
de la fonction publique sont moins
attractives qu'il ne l'était à une
époque et
et
on a aussi enfin on subit aussi des
conséquences d'un marché du travail plus
tendu sur les dans les domaines
scientifiques
donc
la disposition nouvelle qui a été
introduite dans la dans la loi nucléaire
et qui nous permet d'avoir une nouvelle
corde à notre trac avec des contrats de
droit privé elle est réellement bien
venue parce qu'elle va nous permettre
effectivement
d'offrir des conditions alors pour les
personnes qui ne sont pas fonctionnaires
et qui souhaitent rejoindre la scène des
conditions effectivement
peut-être amélioré en termes
d'attractivité c'est en tout cas un
sujet qu'on va qu'on va travailler mais
mais c'était réellement important
effectivement de de pouvoir avoir cette
source nouvelle dans le contexte de
tension que l'on connaît sur les
scientifiques en général et dans le
nucléaire en particulier
sur les sujets
internationaux et en particulier
européen merci pour votre
question et effectivement
je voudrais remettre en perspective le
chemin parcouru depuis plus d'une
vingtaine d'années cette association
donc des responsables d'autorité de
sûreté d'Europe où elle n'ira elle a été
créée à l'initiative d'ailleurs dans
Dracul Lacoste en 1999 finalement pour
combler un vide qui était le besoin de
construire quelque chose entre autorité
de sûreté européenne dans un contexte où
la Commission européenne n'a pas
réellement de compétences techniques et
d'expérience du contrôle des
installations nucléaires et où pour
autant il y avait une attente finalement
des citoyens d'avoir un niveau de sûreté
le plus harmonisé le plus cohérent
possible à l'échelle européenne et donc
en 20 ans il s'est construit
de manière au bottomop comme on dit
c'est à dire
de façon
par la base ce sont les autorités de
sûreté nationale qui l'ont qui l'ont qui
l'ont fait un niveau de sûreté harmonisé
sur la base de ce qu'on appelle les
niveaux de référence de sûreté qui sont
grosso modo des exigences
quasi réglementaires et que les
responsables d'autorité de sûreté se
sont engagés à transcrire si je
n'utilise ce terme dans leur
réglementation nationale et ça ça a
conduit aujourd'hui à ce que les
réglementations en sûreté nucléaire de
l'ensemble des pays d'Europe soit très
similaires avec un niveau d'exigence qui
est très similaire et ça c'est déjà un
premier pas extrêmement important
alors c'est pas on n'est pas arrivé au
bout du chemin et aujourd'hui le travail
dans cette association on l'axe
justement sur les sujets
d'intérêt partagé par la plupart des
pays qui sont au fond
dans quelles conditions on peut
prolonger l'exploitation pour suivre
l'exploitation des réacteurs nucléaires
les plus anciens nous sommes beaucoup
d'entre nous confrontés à cette même
question et donc au fond comment nous
assurons nous que nous allons y répondre
avec grosso modo les mêmes niveaux
d'exigence ou des niveaux d'exigence
suffisamment voisins
même question sur les petits réacteurs
modulaires qui finalement
dont les porteurs de projets frappent à
la porte des différentes autorités en
Europe et plus largement d'ailleurs et
donc là aussi on y répond en ça a été
évoqué par Bernard d'Orzu on y répond en
mettant en place des processus d'examen
conjoints des projets qui sont qui sont
présentés
autre exemple on a cité le changement
climatique bah là c'est pareil c'est
c'est un sujet qui concerne beaucoup
d'entre nous enfin et en Europe à peu
près de la même manière
la question des compétences également
elle a fait l'objet de discussion parce
que nous sommes confrontés aux mêmes
sujets de compétences la question des
soudeurs ont souvent évoqué ici en
France elle se pose exactement de la
même manière dans les autres pays
européens enfin je cite les sourir mais
c'est vrai de l'ensemble des des
compétences en matière nucléaire voilà
des exemples de sujets que nous allons
traiter dans les années à venir alors
dans le cadre de cette association mais
plus largement dans les discussions que
nous avons avec nos homologues européens
et au-delà
poursuivre passer à Géraldine sur la
partie médicale et ensuite pierre sur
[Musique]
et qui fait partie des points de
contrôle important que la SN va aller
inspecter sur le sur le terrain pour la
médecine nucléaire les fréquences de
contrôle vont varier entre trois ans à 5
ans 5 ans lorsque on va avoir un service
qui va effectuer essentiellement des
activités diagnostiques et puis trois
ans pour les services pour lesquels on a
le plus dangereux de radioprotection qui
eux vont pratiquer de la radiothérapie
interne vectorisée avec des doses
engagées pour le patient qui sont
extrêmement importantes
en ce qui concerne les donc les déchets
et les effluents il va y avoir bien sûr
un suivi et un contrôle des rejets dans
l'environnement qui va se faire au
travers du réseau d'assainissement et
généralement par l'intermédiaire d'un
stockage dans des cuves qu'on va appeler
des cuves de décroissance qui vont
permettre de faire des croître
l'activité qui est qui se trouve à
l'intérieur de ces cuves avant qu'on la
rejette dans le réseau c'est encadré par
une décision de 2008
décisions pour laquelle on a rajouté une
circulaire assez récemment au moment où
ont commencé à arriver de nouveaux radio
pharmaceutiques et en particulier le
lutétium
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
les rejets ils sont ils sont très
faibles c'est rejets dans
l'environnement ils sont encadrés il y a
eu une étude de l'IRSN qui a permis de
vérifier que en accord avec ce qui avait
été calculé on a des logiciels spécial
qui permettent d'évaluer les
conséquences sanitaires de ces rejets
sachant que les conséquences sanitaires
sont en particulier importantes pour les
personnes qui vont aller réaliser de la
maintenance in situ dans les
établissements et qui sont celles qui
seraient a priori le plus le plus exposé
par ces
par ses effluents lorsqu'ils sont encore
à l'intérieur de l'établissement et
avant qu'il soit rejeté en respectant
bien entendu les limites de rejet donc
les conséquences sanitaires elles sont
très inférieures à un millicit verte y
compris pour les personnels qui seraient
les plus exposés qui seraient les
personnels qui seraient amenés à faire
de la maintenance
alors ce
l'idée de d'aller regarder ce qui se
passe sur les effluents et les déchets
en médecine nucléaire est en fait
particulièrement importante parce que là
on va toucher à la manière dont on doit
s'organiser lorsque vont arriver de
nouvelles innovations c'est ce qui s'est
passé lorsque sont arrivés de nouveau
radio pharmaceutiques comme le lutetium
qui pose cette fois-ci le problème
devant une arrivée
de
beaucoup de nombreux patients qui vont
être traités avec le lutétium et pour
lequel il faudrait recueillir les
effluences c'est à dire concrètement les
urines donc le problème qui se pose
c'est comment on va adapter la
réglementation à l'arrivée de ces
nouveaux radio nucléides le lutet sur
mon est un on est un exemple pour bien
entendu toujours arriver à contrôler les
rejets dans
les rejets qui restent inférieurs à
aux normes qu'on a qu'on a mis en place
mais sans que sans que cela finalement
ne nuise à l'arrivée de nouveaux radios
pharmaceutiques donc toute cette
toutes ces réflexions autour des
effluents et des déchets c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est spécifique à la
mer à la médecine nucléaire et c'est
quelque chose qui va nous préoccuper
beaucoup qui nous préoccupe déjà
beaucoup mais qui va nous préoccuper
beaucoup dans les années qui viennent
pour adapter cette décision de 2008 qui
donc qui gère les effluents la gestion
des effluents et des déchets pour les
établissements de médecine nucléaire et
au regard des nouvelles avancées des
nouveaux innovations thérapeutiques et
des nouveaux médicaments
radiofharmaceutiques qu'on va qu'on va
pouvoir utiliser donc ça ça fait partie
de la de la charge de travail qui est à
venir et on a des discussions qui sont
en cours
avec notamment les la société française
de médecine nucléaire pour pour essayer
de d'anticiper le mieux possible
l'arrivée de ces nouveaux radios
pharmaceutiques jusqu'à la manière dont
on va gérer les effluents et les déchets
qui vont être consécutives à cette à
cette utilisation
la deuxième question que vous me posiez
ça concernait je crois le l'organisation
de la physique médicale donc là aussi ça
fait partie des ça fait partie des
points qui sont contrôlés et qui sont
contrôlés pour toutes les pour toutes
les installations mais également pour
les services de médecine nucléaire
donc l'organisation de la physique
médicale il existe un guide de
méthodologie qui a été édité par la
Société Française de Physique médicale
et qui permet de d'aider les services à
écrire ce document donc de plan
d'organisation qui est un document qui
va décrire l'organisation et le
fonctionnement de la physique médicale
au sein même d'un d'établissement et
cette organisation de la physique
médicale va permettre de suivre va
permettre d'évaluer les pratiques et en
particulier d'aider à l'optamination des
doses qui sont délivrés alors ce qu'on
voit effectivement en médecine nucléaire
c'est que depuis 2018
si on s'intéresse particulièrement au
plan d'organisation de la physique
médicale il a été jugé satisfaisant en
2022 dans plus de 80% des cas avec une
évolution qui est qui est assez nette et
assez positive et assez marquée depuis
2018 avec donc des plantes
d'organisation donc la manière dont on
dont cette organisation va être décrite
qui sont jugés Satis faisants et qui ne
font j'allais dire qu'ils ne font pas
partie aujourd'hui des alertes qu'on
adresse à la profession alors qu'on
maintient l'alerte sur le sur la bonne
gestion des déchets des effluents
terminé par Pierre bois peut-être sur
l'observatoire
merci Bernard et merci monsieur le
député par votre question de porter la
lumière sur sur cet observatoire des
projets de reprise et conditionnement de
déchets et d'éléments tellement qu'un
objet un petit peu nouveau dans notre
rapport annuel vous l'avez observé qui
est également le fruit et le reflet d'un
important travail de notre côté alors
concrètement de quoi parle-t-on il
s'agit d'un tableau qui figure dans
notre rapport annuel bon la page 350 je
vous laisse le loisir de lire les 349
qui précèdent dans l'ordre que vous
préférerez ce tableau présente pour les
principaux projets de reprise et de
conditionnement de déchets et de
démantèlement les jalons les enjeux à
court terme et le point où nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire quels
sont les étapes majeures à franchir dans
les années qui viennent pour faire
avancer ces projets qui parfois ont des
échéances qui sont extrêmement
lointaines dans le temps
donc évidemment ce tableau est
synthétique donc c'est aussi à prendre
comme une clé de lecture vers les autres
sections du rapport qui viennent parler
de manière plus détaillée des objets qui
figurent
la vocation de ce tableau elle est
double d'une part c'est de donner du
sens au contrôle et à l'action le
contrôle des autorités l'action des
exploitants qui font face à des projets
qui s'étale sur plusieurs décennies on
parle dans certains d'entre eux
d'échéance qui peuvent se trouver en
2070 pour certains même au-delà de 2100
il est important avec des échéances
aussi lointaines d'être en mesure et de
démontrer notre capacité à entreprendre
dès à présent les premiers pas qui sont
nécessaires pour y arriver et de donner
ainsi du sens à l'action des personnes
qui travaillent aujourd'hui quand bien
même les échéances des projets sont très
éloignés dans le temps et dépassent très
probablement
des périodes dont elles pourront être le
témoin donc cette démarche donne du sens
à l'action donne du sens au contrôle
elle est également là pour donner de la
visibilité au public à travers une
information qui consiste à dire ce n'est
pas parce que les échéances sont
lointaines qu'ils ne se passe rien
maintenant il se passe des étapes
importantes qui sont les premiers pas de
projet cuisson long et complexe donc ça
donne du sens à l'action ça donne de la
visibilité au public dans le cadre de
notre mission d'information des publics
si je reviens maintenant un petit peu
sur la genèse de cet outil en fait il
provient du constat que vous avez fait
que vous avez reformuler qui est que les
projets de démantèlement et de
récupération de reprise conditionnement
des déchets sont premièrement nombreux
il y en a beaucoup il y a beaucoup
d'installations qui sont liées au
nucléaire historique qu'il convient
aujourd'hui de démanteler d'assainir ils
sont pour beaucoup d'entre eux complexes
alors complexes parce que il y a des
enjeux des enjeux radiologiques
importants les substances ne sont pas
toujours complètement caractérisées ou
alors elles sont dans des formes
physiques qui sont difficiles à
approcher à récupérer parfois les
technologies nécessaires pour les
récupérer ces objets doivent être
définis aujourd'hui et puis les filières
de gestion des déchets ne sont pour
certaines d'entre elles pas encore en
place donc il faut aussi prendre en
compte l'enjeu des filières de stock age
d'échec donc ça donne ça beaucoup de
complexité à ces projets et comme je le
disais précédemment du fait de du nombre
de la complexité de ces projets il
s'inscrivent dans un temps long voire
très lent comme je le disais les
échanges de certains d'entre eux sont
sur plusieurs décennies parfois
séculaires
tenant compte de cet état des choses
nous avons demandé aux principaux
exploitants et principaux responsables
de ces opérations de démantèlement et de
récupération des déchets de mettre en
place que nous avons appelé des
stratégies démantèlement déchets donc
les principaux exploitants ont mis en
place de telles stratégies dans les
années passées ces stratégies ont été
évaluées par la SM le cas échéant avec
l'appui d'expertise de l'IRSN et elles
ont conduit à des prises de position de
la SN qui sont publiques et qui
permettent dans le nombre et la
complexité de ces projets de désigner
quels sont ceux qui doivent être traités
en priorité et qu'elles sont pour
ceux-ci les échéances principales les
jalons à franchir dans les années qui
viennent donc il y a dans un premier
temps derrière cette observatoire un
travail de fond qui est que confronté à
des projets nombreux complexes et ben on
a d'abord identifié les principaux
enjeux et les principaux jalons à
franchir à court terme et à moyen terme
cela s'est traduit également pour l'ASN
par une évolution de notre logique de
contrôle c'est à dire qu'on est passé
d'une logique où notre attention était
plus focalisée sur les échéances à
prescrire pour la finalisation des
opérations que doivent conduire les
exploitants à une logique dans laquelle
nous prescrivons des échéances à plus
court terme qui sont les obligations
auxquelles ils doivent répondre pour
être sûr que les échanges de long terme
seront sécurisés d'une manière ou d'une
autre on sait qu'il va se passer des
choses entre maintenant et 2170 mais ce
n'est pas une raison pour ne pas
entreprendre prioriser et réaliser et
savoir contrôler ce qui se passe dans
les quelques années qui viennent et donc
nous avons également fait évoluer notre
dispositif à la fois pour la
prescription et pour le contrôle vers
une approche plus dynamique qui permet
de prescrire ses habits rendre
opposables aux exploitants les premières
étapes de leur chantier complexe et pour
nous de nous donner les moyens et les
outils pour contrôler la réalisation et
l'exécution de ses premières étapes donc
nous avons introduit en particulier dans
les différents actes que nous rédigeons
des prescriptions qui identifient
au-delà du fait que certaines échéances
sont lointaines un certain nombre
d'échéances plus proches et nous nous
gardons le droit de les faire évoluer
régulièrement pour que les exploitants
soient aussi soumis à des obligations de
court terme qui matérialise l'avancement
de leurs efforts vers les échéances de
plus long terme et donc nous avons
développé également des compétences en
interne pour le contrôle de la maîtrise
des projets complexes par les
exploitants ce qui nous permet de faire
porter notre contrôle pas seulement sur
leur réalisation mais également sur la
manière dont il s'organise pour être
robuste dans ces dans ces projets
complexes donc il y a pour nous une
vraie évolution du positionnement et qui
a été conçu depuis assez longtemps pour
faire face aux enjeux particuliers que
présentent ces enjeux de très long terme
j'aimerais conclure ma réponse par un
message important que nous que la SN
veut souligner la SN considère que les
projets nucléaires ne seront durablement
acceptables que sous la réserve
impérieuse que la filière démontre sa
capacité à résorber au fil du temps les
différents passifs issus du nucléaire
historique donc le démantèlement des
installations qui ont été construites au
moment des débuts du nucléaire celle qui
sont en exploitation aujourd'hui celles
qui sont déjà arrêtées également la
capacité à récupérer conditionner et
stockées de manière conforme aux enjeux
de sûreté les différents déchets qui
proviennent de ce nucléaire historique
et ça c'est un message extrêmement
important dans une période où nous
sommes et le président et le directeur
général l'ont souligné confronté à de
nombreux projets de relance de la
filière des projets du nouveau nucléaire
il est indispensable d'inclure dans la
vision générale l'obligation de
récupérer et résorber les différents
passifs du nucléaire existant et du
nucléaire historique c'est un message
que je tenais à souligner
et le cette observatoire des projets de
reprise et de conditionnement des
déchets et du démantèlement et d'une
contribution à cet objectif commun qui
est bénéfique pour la sûreté qui est
nécessaire du point de vue de la SN
bien je passe la parole à Philippe Bolot
oui alors m'excusant pour mon absence
momentanée liée à une conférence de
presse pour d'autres travaux de l'OPEX
donc j'ai d'abord dire à quoi se réfère
ma question si jamais ça déjà été traité
ou quelqu'un n'a plus lieu d'être c'est
une question en lien avec le réacteur
Jules eurovitch en construction c'est
Cadarache vous ne l'avez pas et abordé
de ma question va être très rapide donc
je on sait on connaît l'utilité de ce de
ce réacteur en construction qui va nous
doter de capacité de recherche unique au
niveau mondial et qui d'ailleurs est le
fruit d'une coopération qui dépasse
largement les frontières de la France et
qui nous permet notamment de d'étudier
le vieillissement des centrales en cours
et donc qui apporte cette capacité à
prolonger leur durée de vie en attendant
d'avoir les nouvelles capacités de de
production donc il est très utile dans
le franchissement donc de l'outil
nucléaire ancien vers le nouveau donc on
imagine tous le l'importance de ce de ce
réacteur de recherche ce réacteur
scientifique dont on sait cependant
qu'il y a un certain nombre d'efforts
financiers qui restent à produire dans
votre rapport vous en faites l'analyse
au travers des des examens que vous avez
pu faire de contrôle de chantier en
disant que tout va bien j'aurais aimé
connaître la votre position et votre
regard sur la capacité de la France à
disposer d'un tel outil par rapport à
l'analyse et le suivi de la Sûreté
Nucléaire est-ce que ça pourrait être
aussi
utile à votre à votre ASN de disposer de
cet outil là le plus rapidement possible
Gérard souhaitait-il également
s'exprimer je lui laisse la parole
oui c'est très gentil
en fait d'abord je voulais présenter mes
excuses aux membres de
de le fils et à leurs invités pour cette
arrivée tardive qui n'était pas lié à
une panne d'oreiller mais au fait que le
président l'archet m'avait demandé de
parler en son nom à l'occasion et nous
sommes au coeur du sujet d'un colloque
qui se tient au Sénat actuellement et
aujourd'hui toute la journée sur la
transmutation vous savez que dans la loi
de 91 les trois pistes de recherche pour
la gestion des déchets reposait sur
l'entreposage sur le l'utilisation des
causes géologiques profondes et sur la
transmutation et donc c'est un colloque
qui fait le point sur cette
transmutation le président Larcher
souhaitait s'exprimer et j'ai porté sa
parole et accessoirement la mienne
je voudrais poser
trois questions concrètes mais au
préalable
constater en effet que le renouveau du
nucléaire rend la fonction qui est la
vôtre absolument passionnante et je
voulais dans cette fonction passionnante
alors il y a toute une série de
questions qui ont été évoquées notamment
le besoin quantitatif et la question je
vais vous poser c'est au fond
existe-t-il des
procédures de d'évaluation de la sûreté
nucléaire qui soit différente entre des
projets portés par des exploitants qui
depuis des décennies et il revendique
fièrement d'ailleurs à juste titre cette
expérience
d'année de fonctionnement de réacteurs
qui sont en permanence examinées en
permanence surveiller mais qui
fonctionne avec le travail que vous
devez faire auprès de création nouvelle
qui ont souvent
s'appuient sur ce que j'appellerai des
maquettes numériques qui n'ont pas
évidemment l'expérience qui n'ont pas
d'expérimentation et
vous avez cependant la responsabilité
je dirais pas de les encourager mais de
les orienter et à un moment de les
autoriser les certifier en sachant par
ailleurs que ces projets sont des
projets en général de plus petites
tailles qui ont vocation à être
industrialisées qui par conséquent en
vocation à être
exportée en tous les cas les promoteurs
de ces projets l'imaginent et donc
exporter au moins en Europe et c'est là
où le votre action européenne est
absolument indispensable parce que y
a-t-il vis-à-vis des projets nouveaux
qui n'ont pas de de référence qui n'ont
pas de d'années de fonctionnement
d'expérimentation ou de démonstrateur
industriels préalable avez-vous des
techniques particulières pour pouvoir
répondre à ce type d'interrogations ça
c'est question générale trois questions
beaucoup plus concrètes
la première c'est qu'une interrogation
est-ce que vous avez un sentiment en
comparaison en comparant pardon
l'exploitation des réacteurs nucléaires
français qui s'efforce d'être plus
flexible
est-ce que cela peut avoir des
conséquences sur leur sécurité leur
sûreté pardon par rapport à des
réacteurs qui sont gérés en base d'une
façon constante première question
deuxième question le couvercle le
couvercle ça veut dire quoi
[Musique]
accepter de poser le de faire
fonctionner avec le couvercle l'existant
s'offre tard alors le retard c'est c'est
quoi et c'est combien
et puis troisième question pratique
en Chine on a constaté des difficultés
avec des gaines de crayons de
combustibles avez-vous des retours d'EDF
qui a un dossier d'analyse sur ces
anomalies et le cas échéant est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer que flamant fil qui
connaît bien des vicissitudes comme tous
les projets pilotes risquent d'être
interpellé par ces dysfonctionnements
constatés en Chine et transposer
j'aurais une filet je vous avais promis
trois questions mais j'ai deux
observations plus politiques mais la
première je suis très intéressé
pensez-vous que le délai dans quel délai
sur la date de sigeo la SN pourrait
s'exprimer et deuxième sujet assez
politique
mais comment vivez-vous
l'intérêt de la justice pour le
fonctionnement des centrales nucléaires
quand la cour d'appel de Bordeaux
condamne EDF pour faute civile
alors que vous avez en tant qu'autorité
de sûreté vous avez considéré que
une confirmation instant l'incident
relevait du degré 0 c'est-à-dire dans
l'exploitation normale sans prise de
risque particulière ni faute reconnu de
l'exploitant moi je suis passionné très
heureux que la justice s'intéresse au
nucléaire mais je voudrais savoir quelle
est sa compétence sur le sujet est-ce
qu'elle vous a abordé est-ce qu'elle
s'efforce de puisque l'école des
magistrateurs est à Bordeaux est-ce
qu'il y a un lien de cause à effet ce
qu'il y a des sections des magistrats
formés qui peuvent avec d'une façon avec
autorité notoriété intellectuelle et
morale dire non non ça ça c'est c'est
responsable ou pas responsable
bien complément et comme vous le savez
l'office est toujours ouvert à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens nous avons
eu également un certain nombre de
questions des personnes qui ont pu nous
suivre ce matin par vidéo et notamment
une question compte tenu de l'importance
du facteur humain ne faudrait-il pas une
Convention collective unique pour le
nucléaire sous-traitant inclus je pense
que on doit avoir un certain nombre de
d'agents de la filière qui doivent nous
suivre ce matin et d'ailleurs c'est tout
à l'heure honneur et on les en remercie
l'objectif aussi de cette audition c'est
évidemment d'éclairer l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens sur ce sujet de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la radioprotection et en
particulier de l'ensemble des personnels
qui sont en charge de des différents
techniques et des différentes
maintenant ce qui peut y avoir et
également une seconde question sur le
bilan de la plateforme d'alerte de l'ASM
voilà savoir
où en sont à la fois les avancées les
conclusions que vous pouvez en tirer à
ce stade je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
suis au député monsieur ministre alors
je vais répondre enfin je vais essayer
de répondre à vos questions qui sont
parfois redoutables je dois le dire
merci
vous le mettez la barre très haute alors
mais je m'appuierais néanmoins sur
quelques soutiens ici notamment bon je
passerai par là Olivier sur la question
du suivi de charge
et puis je
demanderai peut-être un complément en ce
qui concerne le RJH je vais prendre la
parole en début alors pour ce qui
concerne la question sur le RJH bien
évidemment ce n'est pas de
responsabilité ni la mission de
l'Autorité de sûreté de se positionner
sur l'opportunité l'intérêt
l'ensemble des des avantages que
pourrait
permettre la mise en du réacteur tirer
simplement que en ce qui nous concerne
et le RGH fait partie fièrement des
projets qui qui sont des projets lancés
il y a quelques années qui ont rencontré
malheureusement un certain nombre de
difficultés notamment liées en termes de
gestion de projet et sur lesquels
aujourd'hui et nous avons encore un
certain nombre de points à régler avec
l'exploitant constructeur CEA pour
pouvoir arriver au terme de des
procédures qui sont engagées en vue de
sa mise en service c'est un réacteur qui
est une certaine manière complexe parce
que il est très ambitieux dans ses
fonctionnalités l'idée a été d'en faire
un réacteur à plusieurs fins et le fait
de faire un réacteur unique à plusieurs
fins à complexifier de manière
redoutable sa conception et donc
aujourd'hui sa réalisation donc d'une
certaine manière s'il y avait un retour
d'expérience à tirer de ce réacteur qui
répond à des besoins
indiscutables c'est que
attention et on le voit dans d'autres
projets attention à la complexité liée
au fait de vouloir avoir une ambition un
peu enveloppe en ce qui concerne les
finalités des outils c'est un peu le
couteau suis-je j'avais le mot à la
bouche mais c'est un peu différent à
l'étranger quand je vois et je ferai de
parallèle avec les réacteurs de
puissance de nouvelles génération on a
plutôt tendance à vouloir faire des
choses qui qui sont enveloppe en France
de haute technologie et parfois c'est
compliqué c'est pas exactement la même
approche à l'étranger donc c'est ce
n'est pas ça ne remet pas en cause
l'utilité bien évidemment du réacteur
mais un c'est un réacteur difficile à
construire et à mettre en service deux
il a été vu dans une vision un peu
enveloppe de ses fonctionnalités qui
peut expliquer en partie ces difficultés
je laisserai compléter ainsi si besoin
sur ce sujet RJH je vais revenir à votre
première question de ce ministre qui
correspond finalement à une évolution
profonde de la manière dont nous nous
sommes menés aujourd'hui à aborder les
relations techniques avec les
exploitants effectivement nous avons
vécu dans un monde d'unicité où on avait
un seul exploitant avec une ingénierie
extrêmement solide qui bénéficiait de
milliers d'années de retour d'expérience
réacteurs c'est effectivement tout à
fait différent lorsque nous fasse nous
sommes face à des startups qui ont des
idées extrêmement innovantes mais qui
ont des projets qui n'ont pas de
maturité suffisante qui n'ont pas encore
fait la preuve du concept parfois qui
ont besoin de s'adosser sur des travaux
de recherche et de développement sur un
certain moment de composants qui sont
essentiels dans leur process et qui
viennent nous voir en nous demandant la
manière dont ils doivent se préparer à
présenter un dossier d'options de sûreté
puis ensuite une demande d'autorisation
création le vrai enjeu c'est de trouver
le moyen sans que bien évidemment ce
soit une un sujet pour la SN qui infinie
va devoir se prononcer exactement
comment orienter le porteur du projet
vers des des choix technologiques
comment l'aider d'une certaine manière à
faire maturer son projet lui donner une
certaine maturité et ça ça nécessite des
tiers il faut absolument qu'il y ait des
tiers qui soient des tiers qui ont cette
expérience dans la technologie les plus
avancées et qui puisse eux-mêmes d'une
certaine manière jouer un rôle de grand
frère par rapport à ces jeunes startups
pour pouvoir les aider dans le processus
de maturation de leur projet nous nous
devons donner de la visibilité sur le
processus d'instruction sur le pro sur
les biens les les concepts de base de
sûreté sur lesquels nous serons tout à
fait vigilants mais cette maturité n'est
pas la même donc on est bien
effectivement devant deux populations
différentes et nous le voyons dans les
multiples contacts que nous avons nous
avons maintenant de nombreux porteurs de
projets futurs qui viennent nous voir
ils sont très ambitieux ils veulent que
ça aille très vite mais c'est
extrêmement compliqué il y a un deuxième
point qui est important par rapport à
cette besoins de maturité des projets
qui est notamment lié au SMS
qui est le fait que nous avons face à
nous des un peu des vendeurs d'abord des
concepteurs qui ne sont pas forcément
dans leur idée initialement les
exploitants donc
c'est un peu différent c'est un peu
voilà et donc
surtout vendre des projets c'est ce que
j'allais dire parce que en fait ils
savent vendre des projets à la tous
niveaux d'ailleurs vis-à-vis de
d'éventuellement de personnes qui sont
prêts à investir
d'autorité publique qui sont prêts à
apprendre des définir un système d'aide
sur des projets qui je l'ai dit du point
de vue technologique n'ont pas toujours
la maturité il y a tous n'arriveront pas
de toute façon à terme donc il va y
avoir des pertes ça c'est certain et ce
sont des projets qui ne vont pas le
sujet de manière globale lié à la mise
en place d'un réacteur nucléaire par
exemple les nos interlocuteurs de
manière extrêmement rare ont en tête ce
qui est lié à au cycle du combustible
qui entoure leur projet de réacteur il
ne regarde pas finalement l'amour du
cycle finalement les souvent ils nous
présente des projets avec des des
combustibles qui n'existent même pas il
y a pas d'usine encore de fabrication
des combustibles qui sont à un niveau
d'enrichissement extrêmement élevé qui
pourrait poser un problème en matière
prolifération et puis bien évidemment il
se préoccupe pas du cycaval c'est à dire
finalement mais ensuite les déchets
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait commencer
traiter
il se préoccupe pas non plus vous avez
parlé de d'installation un peu
décentralisée possible
finalement bon on ne sera pas dans un
site nucléaire avec des barbelés pour
lesquels il y a des agents de sécurité
en permanence comment prend-on en compte
la sécurité par rapport aux actes de
malveillance pour ces réacteurs
extrêmement innovants et vous c'est pas
seulement une question de en fait de
d'approche différente ou de maturité
différente de nos interlocuteurs c'est
aussi des gens qui qui ont besoin de
faire un chemin c'est possible mais être
aidé pour pouvoir avoir une vision
globale de du projet qui nous est
présenté et notre rôle c'est bien
évidemment de les éclairer au maximum
sans jamais franchir la Ligue du conseil
c'est ça c'est tout à fait important
donc il y a vraiment un besoin et c'est
ce que nous faisons passer comme message
au point public il y a un besoin de
renforcer le l'aide de grand frère que
je disais pour à la fois donner de la
visibilité large au projet et puis aider
à la maturité des sujets technologiques
voilà je vais laisser peut-être la
parole à Olivier sur la partie du suivi
charge et puis peut-être que Julien
collet pourrait répondre sur le
couvercle et sur leur ex tie Chan pour
les combustibles
juste en complément sur le sur le
dernier point sur les questions de
procédure d'évaluation
deux exemples c'est ces petits réacteurs
recours souvent à des concepts de sûreté
passive c'est-à-dire ne mettant pas en
œuvre de pompe de système nécessitant
justement de d'électricité et donc ça
nécessite finalement la performance de
ces systèmes passifs qui fonctionnent
j'allais dire sur la base des lois de la
physique nécessite d'être démontré et
pas seulement par des simulations on a
aussi besoin d'expérience parce qu'on
voit bien sur tout un tas de sujets les
limites que peut avoir les simulations
voilà les calculs ont montré que et
finalement on a été démenti à posteriori
par l'expérience donc en tant
qu'autorité de sûreté on est très friand
de preuves aussi basées sur des
expérimentations plus concrètes autre
exemple c'est les procédés de
fabrication dit additifs donc voilà
c'est c'est très classique ça devient
classique maintenant mais là aussi c'est
pas des technologies on a beaucoup
d'expérience en tout cas dans le sur
lesquelles on a beaucoup de retours
d'expérience dans le nucléaire et il y a
besoin je reprends ce terme de qualifier
c'est-à-dire de démontrer l'atteinte des
performances et ça naturellement ça va
nécessiter un travail d'autant plus
approfondie d'autant plus important que
les technologies sont en rupture avec ce
qu'on connaît dans le lierre ou dans
l'industrie en général
la question de du suivi de charge
à partir du moment où c'est pris en
compte j'allais dire explicitement et où
les les paramètres finalement de
fonctionnement de l'installation sont
sont prévues pour il n'y a pas de
conséquences néfastes en termes de
sûreté aujourd'hui les réacteurs
beaucoup de réacteurs des DF en sont en
suivi de charge et ça ne pose pas de
difficultés particulières au plan de la
sûreté alors il peut arriver qu'on
demande la limitation du suivi de charge
dans des circonstances particulières
justement quand il y a par exemple des
anomalies
et on l'a fait dans le cas de la
corrosion sous contrainte où on veut
effectivement stabiliser la puissance
pour éviter les variations
de température ou de pression dans tel
ou telle circuit
pour des raisons justement de
préservation de tel ou telle équipements
qui est qui présente un défaut donc on
peut être amené oui pour des raisons de
sûreté à limiter le suivi de charge mais
en tant que tel ça n'est pas une
situation d'exploitation qui pose
problème aucunement en termes de sûreté
peut-être sur ce point suivi je
rajouterais que effectivement les
installations sont été prévues ou
adaptés pour mais aujourd'hui on est
devant une gestion suivie de charge qui
est qui reste non pas limité mais qui
restent dans une épure qui avait été
prévue dans un contexte de production
nucléaire ou plusieurs
installations
production d'électricité pardon était en
service y compris des installations
carbonées et donc le suivi de la demande
d'électricité pouvait être d'ajustement
être répartie sur des moyens divers pas
seulement sur les moyens nucléaires dans
une perspective de moyen long terme dès
lors que les moyens de production
carbonées en vocation à disparaître en
fait le suivi de chat et que la priorité
sera donnée au moyen de production
renouvelables le suivi de charge peut
prendre plus d'importance évidemment et
donc il y aura peut-être à étudier la
capacité du nucléaire à faire face à des
suivis de charges plus plus rapide plus
fréquent que ce n'est aujourd'hui le cas
et ça pourrait être un sujet de
réflexion en ce qui concerne la
poursuite d'exploitation à long terme
peut-être que ça peut produire il faut
l'étudier des phénomènes de
sollicitations particulières de fatigue
particulière qui pourrait conduire à ce
que la poursuite d'exploitation à long
terme quand je dis à long terme c'est
au-delà de 60 ans puisse être n'ont pas
écourté mais être ajusté contenu de
l'état de sollicitation qui sera celui
de l'installation nucléaire du fait
qu'elle aura réalisé du suivi de charge
d'ailleurs les installations nucléaires
qui sont aujourd'hui parfois en retrait
tout en étant acceptable bien évidemment
mais au niveau sûreté par rapport aux
autres réacteurs ce sont des réacteurs
que l'on protège un peu on dit cela on
ne feront pas de suivi de charge parce
que on sait qu'ils ont un niveau de
sûreté qui est un peu inférieur tout en
étant acceptable donc il peut y avoir
une incidence à long terme moyen long
terme du suivi de charge
alors Julien peut-être sur les questions
concernant le couvercle de cuve et le
Rex Tyson
voilà oui sur le couvercle de la cuve de
Flamanville
peut-être d'abord un élément de contexte
nous avions pour la première fois en
fait pris une décision en 2018 pour
l'utilisation de ce couvert ce qu'il
faut bien voir c'est quand cette
décision a été prise en 2018 on avait
bien dit que le couvercle ne posait pas
de problème de sûreté à court terme et
en fait quand la décision avait été
adoptée compte tenu de la date alors
envisagée pour la mise en service du
réacteur on pouvait estimer à ce que ce
couvercle
aurait pu être utilisé pour une durée
d'environ 4 à 5 ans
depuis vous le savez le projet a pris du
retard et en fait la demande que EDF
nous a fait récemment en fait conduit à
n'utiliser le couvercle que sur un cycle
de fonctionnement qui devrait durer
entre 15 et 18 mois normalement et donc
en termes de sûreté voilà la situation
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui en fait
elle est très largement incluse dans les
considérations que nous avions examinées
à l'époque
ensuite par rapport effectivement un
considérant qui figure dans la décision
qu'a récemment prise la SN et qui dit
effectivement l'utilisation du couvercle
elle est elle est acceptable pour un
pour un cycle pour autant si le
calendrier du projet continue de glisser
EDF devra un moment se reposer la
question de est-ce que finalement il
n'est pas plus pertinent de changer le
couvercle avant le démarrage du réacteur
ce qui présente à quelques
quelqu'un intérêts notamment en termes
de radioprotection ça évite
de changer un couvercle qui est devenu
une pièce radioactive ça évite également
la production d'un déchet radioactif
voilà par rapport à ça voilà il faut
dans le décret d'autorisation de
création de Flamanville il y a une date
limite qui est mentionnée pour la mise
en service du réacteur et qui est en
avril 2024
et quand on a pris cette décision sur
l'utilisation du couvercle on l'a fait
au regard de ce contexte qui est
normalement le réacteur devrait démarrer
avant le 10 avril 2024 et d'une certaine
manière le considérant qu'on a mentionné
c'est aussi
d'inviter EDF si jamais il serait amené
à demander au gouvernement de reporter
la date limite pour la mise en service
du réacteur de reconsidérer à cette
occasion dans sa demande la question du
couvercle
voilà donc c'est la voilà pour expliquer
la démarche qui a été qui a été
considéré concernant le retour
d'expérience donc de tyshan sur le
combustible le combustible du réacteur
c'est un retour d'expérience donc il a
mis en évidence des phénomènes multiples
tout d'abord une différence entre la
modélisation qui avait été faite du cœur
et puis ce qui observait en termes de
répartition de puissance à l'intérieur
du cœur ça c'est quelque chose qui avait
été vu dès les premiers essais en
puissance du réacteur de tyshan et puis
bien sûr les dégradations qui ont été
observées sur le combustible et qui ont
conduit à l'arrêt du réacteur il y a
quelques années
et qu'il a aussi mettre en évidence des
phénomènes multiples tout d'abord un
phénomène
de corrosion et de dégradation des lames
qui tiennent qui retiennent les crayons
de combustibles et qui ont conduit un
percement des gaines des gaines du
combustible qui constituent la première
barrière dans un réacteur et puis
également des oscillations d'ensemble du
cœur du réacteur qui ont conduit à dû un
frottement pour des frottements des
assemblages et une usure des
de la structure du combustible
nous avons demandé évidemment à EDF de
prendre en compte ce retour d'expérience
et de notamment de le prendre en compte
en vue de la mise en service du réacteur
sur lequel nous aurons à nous prononcer
d'ici la fin de cette année ou le début
de l'année prochaine
par rapport à ces différents sujets EDF
à
sur le premier sujet de la répartition
de puissance EDF a fait des propositions
pour expliquer l'origine de la
différence
la prise en compte dans le dans le
système de surveillance du coeur et en
toute état de cause c'est des choses qui
seront vérifiées lors des essais de
démarrage de flamants ville 3
sur les autres phénomènes EDF a proposé
un renforcement des des assemblages
des assemblages qui seront chargés dans
dans la cuve du réacteur et a notamment
dès le premier chargement en fait
approvisionner des assemblages renforcés
qui seront positionnés en périphérie du
coeur et qui permettront notamment de
prévenir le risque de percement des
gaines de réacteurs
et enfin il y a un sujet qui lui devrait
être traité à plus moyen terme c'est le
sujet de l'oscillation du combustible à
l'intérieur du coeur qui en fait lié au
comportement de l'eau à l'hydraulique en
fait de la cuve et ça ça nécessitera des
adaptations en fait du dispositif qui
est situé au fond de la cuve qui en fait
un mélangeur qui a pour rôle d'assurer
la bonne distribution de l'eau et qui en
fait à l'origine de ces de ce phénomène
de
voilà de mouvement du coeur et ça c'est
un sujet qui est un peu plus moyen terme
puisque ça nécessite des développements
des essais sur ma quête pour être pour
être qualifié et donc qui pourra être
mis en oeuvre voilà probablement d'ici
quelques années et voilà et supprimer à
la source ce phénomène d'usure des
assemblages
je terminerai par les deux questions des
internautes à distance alors la première
question je la reconnais je pense même
reconnaître la personne qui l'a posé
c'est une question récurrente qui m'est
adressée alors je vais faire la réponse
récurrente que j'adresse et que
l'évolution de la convention collective
des salariés de du nucléaire dans son
ensemble c'est la situation bien sûr des
des sous-traitants n'est pas de la
responsabilité de de la SN
néanmoins les sujets qui sont évoqués à
travers les les
comportements humains les facteurs
eux-mêmes et organisationnels ce sont
des sujets sur lesquels nous travaillons
qui ne sont pas liés à la convention
collective et l'interlocuteur qui a posé
cette question le sait très bien
puisqu'il est membre de notre comité sur
ce sujet et nous veillons à ce que les
facteurs humains soient intégrés par
l'ensemble de la filière et des
sous-traitants mais ce n'est pas lié à
la convention collective
concernant le bilan de la plateforme qui
a été mise en place alors c'est une
plateforme qui a été mise en place en mi
2018 par l'ASN plateforme de signalement
et qui correspond en fait à la
découverte indirgularité au début
c'était le Creusot où nous avons
souhaité mettre en place un moyen pour
que chacun puisse de manière
non pas anonyme mais discrète nous
signaler nous
garantissons à la confidentialité des
déclarations qui sont faites ces
déclarations sont traitées par une
équipe à part qui a des obligations
extrêmement strictes de garantir de
confidentialité des personnes qui ont
déclaré nous avons un dispositif qui
fonctionne afin 2022 nous avons eu au
total alors pas seulement sur la
plateforme parce qu'il y a aussi des
signalements qui sont faits par écrit
tout simplement 200 signalements qui ont
été faits à la SN à travers le portail
de signalement et les déclarations
écrites
il y a 60% des signalements qui sont
traités par des actions de la SN 40% de
correspondant à des signalements qui ne
sont pas de notre responsabilité qui
sont pas de notre ressort qui
correspondent pas à des sujets sur
lesquels nous avons des moyens d'action
dans 25% des cas nous réalisons des
inspections c'est à dire que nous allons
voir sur le terrain ce qui nous a été
dit pour vérifier de manière bien vivant
discrète on fait en sorte que
l'exploitant qui est contrôlé ne
connaissent pas la source d'information
pour pouvoir aller faire cette
inspection et nous nous mettons cette
inspection sur ce sujet dans un ensemble
de sujets de manière à le rendre
discrète et puis nous arrivons à constat
que 10% de ces sujets après
investigation après inspection sont
vraiment des sujets sérieux alors ils
seront parfois l'objet de déclaration à
la justice lorsque ce sont effectivement
des des des fois graves et puis il y a
des questions de traitement qui sont
possibles des questions sérieuses qui
sont traitées avec les exploitants alors
qu'est-ce que nous avons constaté de
manière générale beaucoup de choses bien
évidemment l'essentiel des constats
d'irrégularités sont liés en général à
des contrôles qui ont été déclarés mais
qui n'ont pas été faits
ou à des à des
usurpations d'identité l'accès en zone
est extrêmement contrôlée donc on
utilise le badge d'une autre personne
pour rentrer à zone alors qu'on ne doit
pas le faire on ne peut pas le faire ou
alors on utilise on fait une déclaration
comme quoi on était en zone alors qu'on
n'était pas donc il y a toute une série
de
fraudes qui sont liés à cette usurpation
d'identité ou des contrôles qui sont
passés ou qui sont mal fait ou dans les
résultats sont modifiés c'est la raison
pour laquelle notamment sur la partie
contrôle et je rebouclerai par rapport à
un des premiers points que nous avons
évoqué nous souhaitons véritablement qui
est à travers les nouveaux nucléaires et
la mobilisation de la filière une
réflexion approfondie sur la
numérisation de manière à renforcer la
traçabilité des contrôles qui sont faits
à rendre plus compliqué la falsification
des résultats pour sécuriser la filière
je pense que face aux enjeux du nouveau
nucléaire il faut être extrêmement
vigilant sur ce sujet et j'ai écrit
récemment au donneur d'ordre pour
attirer leur attention
très bien ben écoutez nous vous
remercions pour cette présentation de
l'état de la sûreté nucléaire en France
pour l'année 2022 pour les réponses
également apportées à nos interrogations
ainsi que pour la vigilance et
l'indépendance dont vous faites
constamment preuve cette audition a
permis d'éclairer nos collègues et nos
concitoyens sur ces questions majeures
et l'Office remplit ici sa mission tout
comme la SN le fait en permanence et
nous aurons l'occasion évidemment d'ici
quelques temps de revenir vers vous que
ce soit concernant la saisine comme pour
d'autres sujets à l'avenir merci à tous
c'est nous pouvons lever la séance